thank you very much
good afternoon members officers and
members of the public
welcome to the joint standards committee
meeting on thursday 3rd
september 2020 my name is councillor
michael helm and i'm chairman of this
committee
the meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april in response to the
covid 19
pandemic there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your micromain clone remains
muted
and your video video feed is off and not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noise and
avoid any unintentional disturbance
the meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and then by press being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during this item
please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time members are
reminded apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave for
a meeting the check function should not
be used
for questions or any other purpose
and members do not speak over each other
please
members when speaking are and referring
to agenda paper please reference the
page
paragraph number and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone and video
now i i may ask the officers taking part
in the meeting to introduce themselves
starting mr crouch
thank you chairman simon quelch and i'm
the monitoring officer
uh berna good afternoon members bernie
casey clark to today's committee
thank you is there anybody else present
i don't believe there are any other
officers present chairman
okay if you can now carry out the roll
call of members to confirm who's
intended in attendance please
thank you chairman members i will take
you to the through the attendance list
in alphabetical order
councillor bassinger good afternoon
bernard
presents thank you councillor chana
good luck good afternoon sorry just had
a bit of trouble getting
mute unmuted rather thanks thank you
councillor helm is present thank you
councillor jarvis
afternoon a present thank you uh
councillor keys
good afternoon burner president thank
you councilman
councillor mays a present
good afternoon councillor nunn
yes um hello
thank you cancer stamp uh
present burner thank you councillor
stilts
good afternoon i'm present thank you
thank you german
is that all mr hudson isn't president i
take it
no the independent person is not present
no he would have been part of the office
i have apologies for absence please
bernard
yes we've received apologies for absence
from councillor thompson and councillor
keys is
substituting for her today yes i've got
that thank you very much
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosure with union interests other
pecuniary interests and non-pecuniar
interests
raising to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they've become aware should
the need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has a an interest to
declare please use the chat function
now to indicate and i will invite them
to speak
bernar is the only one wishes to declare
anything
and not at the moment chairman uh i just
i hope i just
need to check because um
no i have nobody in the in the chat feed
thank you chairman thank you for that
four stanzas complaint councillor
christie morris for the move to item
four
stanley's complaint chrissy morris found
on pages five to forty four
in a moment i will call on the lead
legal specialist and monitoring officer
to present the report members are in
mind that if you wish to speak
please use it make it known using the
chat function within the meeting it
won't come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
concise
mr crouch can you present the uh report
please
uh thank you chairman yes now
apologies sorry um mr quelch could we
just check it
uh for members who are actually in
attendance as well please
apologize i overlooked that well i
overlooked it as well sorry
are there any other members in
attendance
yes councillor benford and councillor
thank you very much
thank
that's great thank you very much members
chairman before before mr welch is
allowed to speak could i ask a question
i think is relevant for the beginning of
the meeting please chairman
yes of course you may thank you could i
ask
the monitoring officer before the
meeting starts is
i might have missed it but where is the
letter of complaint
made by the member of the public which
is important to this hearing
i haven't got it in my pack please
chairman i just wanted to be clear i
haven't got
it thank you
simon can you answer that question
please yeah thanks chairman
that relates to obviously uh mr jennings
report um what he's done is
rather than appending the um
letter he has described he has actually
recited the letter
um at paragraph 1.2
of his report which is appendix 2.
page page 42 on the bundle
he sets out the um
the aspects of behavior that
count that mr kelly was complaining
about
chairman can i come back yes i've got
that but i really think it's important
if a member of the public has complained
all the details could be redacted
we need to see what was written because
there could be other things on that
complaint no disrespect to any
monitoring officer and i'm not
putting any disparaging comments forward
chairman i just want this
to be right and proper and that is my
concern we haven't got that
uh written complaint
uh from the complainant thank you
chairman i'll be quiet now but thank you
allowing me
that's no problem at all uh
simon can you uh explain that or can we
have that producer yes i mean there's
there's no requirement for there was no
requirement for mr jennings to append
that
but i can look now um in my file
um to see what that letter says and i
can read it to members if they want me
to
um if you can give me a minute or two to
find it
yeah um if you could just wait one
moment then chairman i'm sorry
that's all right no problem at all simon
oh
[Music]
wow
chairman i i i have that letter
um in front of me um i i can read it out
now or i can read it out later whichever
probably better read out later when we
get to that part of the uh
agenda is that all right with members
yep
thank you chairman thank you yeah that's
fine thank you
right if we uh now move on to your
report please simon
okay there there are in fact chairman to
two investigations and
based on two quite separate uh
complaint letters so a chairman would
you like me just to deal
with the report the first report
and then do members want to ask
questions
and debate it or chairman do you want me
to deal with both reports at the same
time
i think we should do one at a time if
that's all right with members
is that all right agreed agreed okay
um that that chairman will probably mean
that councilor myers will need obviously
to
have two opportunities to speak to
each particular report yes
um so dealing with the the first
complaint
um appendix one of your bundle and it's
page
starting at page seven um in your pack
uh this is a complaint by
councillor dewick and i've actually
appended his letter um
dated the well it's an email dated the
27th of november
last year so members can also see not
only the nature of the complaint but if
you go to page 11
you will see in the
ultimate paragraph how he viewed
councillor morris's behavior and
obviously why he made the complaint
the complaint relates in fact is twofold
um the first one relates to the overview
and scrutiny committee
where where councillor morris um
didn't actually um appear at that
committee as a counselor
um i think he was i think he presented
himself as mr morris or he was certainly
presented
as mr morris and i believe he was
seeking to be there as a member of the
public
and was not representing himself as a
councillor now
there is an issue in relation to that
you may say well
councillor morris was a councillor um
i don't think i've in that in all
respects
at any committee meeting i don't quite
view it like that
um i believe that councilor morris was
actually deliberately presenting himself
as a member of the public
and asking for a right to speak as a
member of the public
and in my view therefore that particular
complaint
i don't think is with a restriction of
the code of conduct and the
localism act
my view is that um
that should be dismissed that particular
part of the complaint
um and that's why i didn't investigate
it further
um then that comes to the second part
which i do believe
is engaged uh as far as the code is
concerned
and that relates to councillor morris's
behavior on the third of october
and the 21st of november last year
and in you've got annexes 2 and 3 that
actually set out
verbatim how that meeting the how those
two meetings went
so members can see for themselves the
flow of the meeting
and at what point councillor morris
spoke at what point the chairman spoke
and the reactions of both now but what i
have done is
at paragraph five on page seven
you'll see that i try to summarize what
actually happened which i hope
you find helpful if not then then just
disregard it
um and rely on your reading of annexes
two and three
and you'll see there my summary of um
both meetings in fact is because i'm
viewing them together
as a sort of a continuing form of
conduct
counselor morris repeatedly spoke over
the chairman at both meetings
the chairman stood on one occasion in
october and four times in november and
members will understand the significance
of that because
of what i set out at paragraph nine
um which sets out the different rules in
our constitution
uh whenever the chairman rises during a
debate
a member then standing shall resume his
seat and the council
shall be silent those are
that's mandatory constitution is saying
that must happen there is no discretion
in a member to say
i will or i won't um it is
mandated by the constitution
um continuing at both meetings
resolutions were passed that counselor
morris should no longer be heard
that were both proposed by the chair
councilor morris spoke after the
resolution
insisting that he could speak despite
the chairman stating
that he needed to be quiet
and then in october uh and this only
relates to the october meeting
um councilor morris refused to leave the
chamber
at the request of the chairman and then
uh finally the chairman prematurely
closed the october meeting
and threatened to close the november
meeting although he did not close
the november meeting um
i interviewed councillor morris
in my office and i have to say council
morris was very cooperative
um although councillor morris denied
um all the allegations that were that
were made
um he denied disrespect and i think in
fact he felt he was the victim
he felt he was disrespected
and he felt that the meeting was closed
not because of his behavior but because
of the conduct of the chairman
uh i have to say council marcus was
respectful during that interview
um he cooperated fully
with the investigation um
but um his in some in summary
he denied completely that he was
responsible
for any of the matters that councillor
dewitt was complaining about
um you'll see
my conclusion
and in my conclusion i've made some
extra remarks
which for you to consider and that is
that i think that
although councilor morris sincerely
believed that he was the wronged person
which is what he said in interview and
i accept that that he sincerely believed
that
um counselor morris focuses
in my view he was focusing in the
interview more on his
rights and seemed to be
unaware of his responsibilities
that a counselor has to
abide by the constitution and i made the
point in my report that
if every councillor decided to interpret
the constitution as as they thought then
we'd have
31 different versions of it and there
would be no opportunity for democracy to
take place
because every councillor would behave
just as they pleased
whenever they pledged i felt that
councillor morris was unaware of
his responsibilities but supremely aware
of his rights
um i concluded you see my conclusion
uh paragraphs 13 and 14 on page nine
that uh he failed to treat the chairman
with respect
and that his behavior could reasonably
regard as bringing
his office or the authority
into disrepute just one little
correction the paragraph
10 that should read 3.2
um not 3.1 typing error
um i put in some sanctions
as well um i know that's not normally
done
members might prefer just to go to my
report itself
not this investigation um
i've tried to tailor that to this
particular situation so that's why it's
slightly different from my report
because i've tried to be
investigation specific
that's that's that's really all i want
to say at the moment chairman
do you want to oh
thank you very much it's about time too
um i just
there's a couple of procedural questions
that i'd like to ask
simon um the first one would be that for
many years
the joint standards committee has been
running unlawfully is that correct
um and lawfully in the sense
that um parish councillors were allowed
to vote
simple question in the report that came
from this
it was found that the joint staff
committee had been operating
unlawfully not illegally unlawfully
for many years is that correct a simple
yes or no answer
because i understand we have time
restraints i i don't understand
the difference between unlawful and
illegal um
let's just let's just stick with it so
that you don't muddy the world
the answer is yeah the answer is that
um the council for many years was
operating
the council excuse me i'm speaking
i'm the councillor you're the officer
i'm asking you the questions
i didn't interrupt you please don't
interrupt me now
simply put yes or no answer will suffice
because of time restraints
has the joint standards committee been
operating
unlawfully for years yes or no please
chairman um this is not about a fight at
all
uh so chairman i've been asking that
question
if i might not answer the question this
isn't to do
with the report here or anything to do
with it
something else to do it needs to do the
report here
tomorrow joint committee
now i've asked a simple question because
in the report it was stated that the
joint standards committee has been
operating
unlawfully for years i would like to
know
if it's been operating unlawfully four
years
why who who is liable or who is
responsible for it running unlawfully
and is it running
unlawfully now because i have some
concerns so if i can get my answers
if i can get my questions answered quite
simply we'll be able to get through this
quite quickly
so yet again i'll put it to simon quelch
simon has this joint standards committee
been operating unlawfully
for years yes or no please um well if
you want to
put it like that yes it has and no it's
not
well yes it has is enough because in the
report it did state that and you've
agreed that with me
um privately on the phone yeah so it's
been operated
whose responsibility was that who's
liable
well the monitoring officer before me
and me
so you are responsible for the joint
stance committee
running unlawfully four years uh yeah um
i came in i came in in two thousand and
i think i became monitoring officer in
2018
um i understand it had been operating
like that for a number of years
um that was then brought to my attention
by an investigator and the mata is now
corrected and we now have a lawful joint
standards committee
right so now it's lawful okay okay so
i'd like to know did the council not put
a resolution forward
for this to be for this committee to be
politically balanced
yes or no answer please i i understood
that on the 22nd of june
the council resolved that political
balance should not apply it
it disapplied the political balance
provisions
okay okay let's move on let's move on
because i don't believe that it's now
politically balanced but there you go
which is against the council resolution
um
come on ask where is um councillor or
sorry clout
count councillor john anderson police
is he resigning uh councillor anderson
is no longer a part of this committee
because he resigned
and did he resigned because he felt to
um disclose that he was a conservative
party member
chairman i i through you i don't know
how relevant these questions
are to this request i'm afraid
councilmember
um
[Music]
where is the independent person
considering that he could make this
morning's meeting but he couldn't make
this one
okay yeah um
he he has he's given his apologies
he is otherwise engaged i tried to get
um
one of the reserves but was unable to do
so
the independent person's presence is not
required by the localism act and he has
submitted
as you know councilor morris his views
in writing which has already been passed
to all members of this committee and
i can read those out so his views on the
report
are available to members i'm not asking
for his views or asking where he was
obviously his bottle's gone um
the committee is that correct is that
the correct procedure
that if an independent person cannot
make commitment and isn't after their
views
that you don't tell anyone is that
i'm sorry chairman i don't know how
relevant this
is to i i thought the questions um
chairman were meant to be relating
to my report that is correct can you
borrow counselor morris can you
confirm yourself please i did
at the start of this i have some
concerns that procedure
isn't being followed the procedure
hasn't been
followed previously and the procedure
isn't being followed now
i have requested that all of my accusers
and the witnesses
were able to be questioned about the
evidence that they have given as is my
common law right if anyone wants to look
it up it's called the confrontation
clause
simon's going to come back and say this
isn't a court but
if you'd like me to read them out i've
got numerous messages from simon
stating article 6 of the european
convention for human rights
which states the um a fair trial
so when it suits the monitoring officer
he's talking about
fair trials and when it doesn't suit the
monitoring officer
i.e to produce the uh the witnesses
and the complaintants against me um you
know it all seems to go out of the
window it doesn't seem
very fair or just so sorry i mean let's
just
just move on because you know time
restraints and everything
um
do you know um i find it quite bizarre
because you're stating
the the uh the um member of the public
that complained
how long have you known the member of
the public that complained
um for many years counselor duik
has been a counselor for many years i
know lots of counsellors
for many years did you
i said the member of the public that has
complained oh sorry i'm sorry
i i thought we were talking about the
first report counsellor
uh morris we're dealing with each report
in turn
i'd like to get this one out of the way
now how long have you known
former tory district councillor tom
kelly ford
with that report at the moment we're
dealing with the report
i lost that one i lost that one later on
right so um can i ask
is morton district council obliged to
follow
the european convention of human rights
yes
that one was for you chris wayne don't
know much do you
um right so let's move on
how many concerns how many councillors
have concerns
about your um perceived
biases mr quoch um accounts uh chairman
this isn't about this is not about me
this is about the report
um you're biased you are biased
you've written the reports you've asked
you for clarifications you might have of
the monetary doctors report will you
confine yourself
what i would like to mention now is you
being in the chair because i believe you
aren't competent enough to be in the
chair
you didn't even know that councillor
silks wasn't the independent person
in the last meeting you was calling the
councillor stills the independent person
you don't even know who's in the room i
need to
provide yourself to report please
i find it strange that we've got someone
that's dumber than lou ferrigno in the
chair for this
you are fluke that's another complaint
so going back to it
so mr quilts
are you maintaining that he was unaware
after being at morton district council
for quite some time that you was unaware
of any of the bullying
and the homophobic comments were you are
you saying that you were completely
um unaware of all that
morris you are you were asked to ask
questions of clarification on the
monitor
office report the monitoring officer
didn't report that
i'm questioning his competence to do the
report he's wrong
joint standards committee unlawfully
for years he failed to tell
the committee when the independent
person wasn't even informed at the last
joint standards committee
of 2019 i'm i'm wondering whether or not
that is incompetence or bias
he
are you scared of the truth councillor
helms i'm not scared of anything but
you're going away from the report
not like you are you look like you are
you can't even get the people in the
committee right
what are you doing in the church are one
and we'll get back on it confined to the
report please
[Music]
um what's the report influenced by
your uh bias towards the conservative
party mr quoch
no that proceed
presupposes i have a bias towards the
conservative party
which i do not
i've i've i've made a complaint about
that haven't i so you have got a
complaint
gone in about you being biased
that is that is not biased when they've
cost this council
thousands of pounds in investigations
that they don't cooperate with
and when you confirm what councilor
that's it you do all this rigmarole for
me whistle blowing
but you'll just send an email out to
someone that hasn't responded to your
emails to tell them to respond to your
emails
that's biased
i'm in a difficult situation here
councillor morris will not
confine himself to the report and asking
questions to monitor officer
he's bringing other items in which are
irrelevant to this meeting
i would ask that he'd be
councilor morris isn't a member of this
committee he's
here representing himself can we do what
you request that's what i want to do
be sure about the process reply to that
please
um yes i mean chairman uh this
is not a court hearing this is a
committee meeting uh
councillor morris is here
to deal with the issues at hand if you
as a committee
feel um as a committee that he is
hindering the transaction of business
namely dealing with these allegations
specific allegations
and you feel that that is interfering
with the business of the committee
then then you're entitled to ask him to
no longer be heard and if you feel he
continues to persist
then i i chairman you can you can you
can have him excluded from this
committee meeting
chairman i can't hear a damn thing i'm
so sorry i can't hear anything call just
a little bit
blurry yeah so exactly what
councilmember said then i i didn't
comprehend at all
but i am beginning to feel chairman i'm
not a joint standards committee for
councillor morrison complaints against
him i'm beginning to feel i'm
over in scrutiny or something because we
are
diverting way away from the report of mr
quelches
and actually i feel that mr coach is now
becoming interrogated
and that is not the purpose of this
committee and we should not allow that
to continue chairman i feel quite
strongly about that
mr quelch is being put in a position as
where i believe he looks to be the
victim and he's been interrogated
i feel which should not be occurring
whatsoever at this committee it's not
the purpose of it
not with its terms of reference and it's
a point of order i'm making about the
process
german and it's against some of our
rules and articles thank you
does anyone want to second that motion
i will second it unless mr morris gives
his assurance he will keep his questions
only to the matter of the report if he
can't give that assurance i will second
that
can you give your assurance please
councillor morris
i'll give my assurance that i will speak
my truth
wherever i need to say something i will
say something
i have not been put into this office to
be quieted
i have exposed along with some other
brave councillors
a bullying culture where threats and
homophobia were right
i am a whistleblower i have exposed this
and now you're trying to quiet me again
there are like most of the customers in
we all need to be conscious that the
sound is incredibly bad
um could we ask members to ensure that
they have their microphones turned off
when they're not partaking in the me
to see if that will help in any way
because it's very hard for anybody
viewing the meeting or anything else to
hear what the proceedings
are um you want me to move to a vote
to can you please repeat that can you
please repeat
your request silence please
and that was julie seconded
thank you thank you chairman i will
members i will take you in alphabetical
order can you please stay clearly
for against abstain
points of older councillor channel seth
didn't second it
she put a condition on that so she needs
to confirm
that she's gonna second that now
well because councillor morris i did ask
for assurances and he said
he is going to continue with his rights
to be heard that he believes he can do
that
and i think actually that actually
highlights the point in the
monitoring officer's report where he
said that he had
uh councillor morris had supreme
knowledge of what his rights may be
but not about his responsibilities and
today is about some responsibilities
we're operating under the constitution
of the council with this joint standards
committee sitting
we have to apply the articles and rules
of our constitution the constitution has
some mandatory things in it chairman
and i believe that actually i am going
to support your
request chairman because actually mr
quelch is being
interrogated and i did not come onto
this committee
expecting to be a seeing and witnessing
simon quelch being interrogated this was
about
uh a meeting to look at the complaints
and to the reports and place
questions on those reports and i'm now
being spoken over so i am going to
second it for those reasons
had mr morris kept purely to the report
and questions on that
i would not be doing this thank you
for the vote
members i will call you in alphabetical
order can you state
clearly for against abstain councillor
bassinger
four because mr quelch has been
interrogated
counselor helm four mr jarvis
thanks berna i think it's a great pity
because i think would be some good
useful information useful comments that
chrissy morris could make
but i'm afraid he has i think
overstepped the mark there he's not
sticking to the point he has been
cautioned
he's made it clear that he won't stick
to the point because he feels that's his
right so
with some hesitation i'm afraid i'm i'm
for that motion
keys for
me
so it counts the maze
counselor maze have we still you're
still with us i can
see you
again uh sounds amazing she's having
real problems hearing what's going on
she's still in the meeting but can
customize can you hear us now
uh yeah against thank you very much
counselor none reluctantly for
that's the stamp um
councilor morris i i really am i'm
really sorry but we cannot conduct this
business
i know you've got your rights and you're
very very a valid member of this council
but we cannot hear this meeting if
you're not going to follow the processes
and the rules
i'm really sorry council morris but i'm
going to have to ask that you
do abide by the rules or i support the
motion as well
and that's that is i don't really want
to do it but i'm going to do it for this
council
is that a four against your abstention
cancer
stamp um oh
god uh um it's it's four
thank you members that's six for
the recommendation two against and no
abstentions
chairman can counsel morris come back on
the next um
out of the meeting please chairman he
can come back no problem at all
as long as he sticks to the procedure
chairman i must make it clear i was only
doing it as a result of what's been
going on here yes i wasn't meaning the
whole
shebang okay
and you don't like it when i bring it up
the majority of you are corrupt
councilor morris i'm so sorry we've had
to take the decision but you've just
know who's in the stopped at the last
minute can we now switch councillor
morrison please follow that vote
thank you
committee members i now invite you to
ask the monitoring officer any questions
please use the tech function if you wish
to speak
can you can you indicate who wants to
speak please
yes chairman councillor stamp counselor
nun and counselor channel have questions
uh stamp
no my burner mine was uh mine was
earlier on i haven't indicated at the
moment to speak
okay sorry it was just right at the
beginning so counselor nun and counselor
channel
counseling counselor okay
thank you very much chairman uh so i
have three
questions chairman of uh for the
monitoring officer
whilst i understand mr quelch
why we're considering the issue
of october i don't
understand why the issue of november
has been included in the report if
the conclusion is that the cancer was
acting as a member of the public i.e
my understanding of the joint standards
committee
is that we're primarily here to consider
breaches of the council plan of conduct
so why did it meet the threshold to be
brought to joint standards committee
um when your clear conclusion
was that um it doesn't amount to a
breach of the code of conduct
do you not believe that to be in some
way double jeopardy
uh no i think this may be a
misunderstanding counselor numb
there were two aspects to um councillor
dewick's complaint
the first was in relation to overview
and scrutiny on the 14th of november
last year my conclusion is that on that
occasion
councillor morris was present in the
committee as a member of the public
not as a councillor hence i don't
believe the cages
the the code is engaged and my view is
that can part of the complaint should be
dismissed
in relation to the second part of the
complaint there
are two council meetings that are
referred to not over the exclusionary
full council meetings
on the 3rd of october and the 21st of
november
on both occasions councillor morris was
present there as
a member of the council yes sorry i i
understand
all of that but but in simple terms
why has the allegation involving mr
boris
been included in the report because that
was the complaint
because the complaint if you read the
complaint letter
um yeah so so i dealt with that
because it was one complaint um
i dealt with it in the report to show
that because that letter would have been
annexed to show
that i dismissed it and why i dismissed
it
so why then sorry
mr why then are we considering it today
well you you could overrule me if you
wanted to
and say the code was engaged um
but um my view is it isn't and therefore
i didn't pursue the investigation
the reason i've included it counselor
nun is because it formed part of the
letter
as one complaint and so for completeness
i wanted the joint standards committee
to see my reasoning
okay thank you for explaining that my
second
question is notwithstanding uh
the terrible situation we're in with
covert 19.
the allegations against councillor boris
in appendix one
right date back to october and november
2019
some 10 months ago why has it taken so
long
to bring this to the joint stance well
there was
um initially um my report was going to
go to joint standards in february
um that had to be cancelled i can't
remember the reason now but that had to
be cancelled
and it was then um programmed to go on
the 27th in fact
the agenda had been issued i believe for
the 27th of march
unfortunately covert 19 and the lockdown
came in so that committee meeting had to
be abandoned
um we we this is the first
joint standards committee that has been
held
since um img has ceased
to be making decisions now it was a
possibility
that img um which was obviously
holding matters in the interim was a
small group of
a small group of
officers and members could have actually
dealt with this issue and i
put that to img but img felt that was
inappropriate
and that it should be dealt with with a
fully constituted joint standards
committee so that meant
um despite my attempts to get it in
february
in march and then later on to img i was
thwarted
not for want to try and cancel the name
thanks my final question is um
what weight should this uh committee
give to the fact that a paragraph eight
in your report
the then chairman of district council
did not wish to bring a complaint
yeah you need to weigh that in the
balance i think that's that's that that
that's wrong with councillor none
um the thing is you've got to decide
decided not submit so much on who was
the complainant
but the conduct and the code of conduct
asks you to consider for example in
relation to 3.2
you must treat others with respect
sometimes a complainant and i've dealt
with
lots of different complaints uh quite a
few recently i have to say
um rather disproportionate amount
recently
councillor nan
sometimes people make complaints about
other
about about complaints that are where
other people are the victim
it's not unusual because sometimes the
victim is unprepared to come forward
for for their own personal reasons okay
thank you very much thank you chad
that's all right anybody else term and
counselor channel and then counselor
stamp
shout out
thank you very much chairman actually
counseling and i must have similar minds
because i was going to refer to
paragraph eight
and regarding um when uh the monitoring
officer spoke to the
chairman of the council at that point
councillor bob boyce
and i was going to ask exactly that same
question because
the rest of the report was silent on
that it didn't make it clear what if
wait any at all have been applied to the
monitoring officer's
um sort of conclusions if you like
bearing in mind that the chairman's
stance on that
so then the other question will ask and
i can't find it now because
i've been moving around and lost it
somebody but mr crouch in that same
report
and i'm sure he'll remember it made the
the sentence that he
sensed that councilor morris really
didn't understand his responsibilities
or words to that effect
sensed um so to me there's
been sensing and really um being clear
on that fact from questions put
so i just wonder if mr quelch could just
expand a bit more
on the sense he had yes was it as a
result
of questioning because we can all sense
certain things so i think it's important
that there's clarity if it's a based on
sense alone
or whether there's something that backs
up that statement
okay chairman chairman yes i understand
the question thank you
um um i didn't
in the interview with councillor morris
which i have to say was quite a friendly
one um
i did not put the question to him
whether he uh about this issue
of whether he was uh
aware of his responsibilities
and so because the question wasn't put i
am i'm basing my view
in paragraph 11 on the fact that
um councilor morris was denying
all the time that he had in any way
interfered with the business that he had
interrupted the chairman
or that this was responsible for
the closure of the october meeting so
although it's because i didn't ask him
the explicit question
what do you say about your response what
is your attitude to responsibility
okay well thank you chairman you were
very clear about he understood his
rights
that my my view of that interview was
that
counselor morris was only
concerned about his rights he had no
sense um of appreciation
of his responsibilities as a counsellor
to
to abide by the constitution along with
all with 30 other
councillors and one more question if i
may chairman mr quelch you did mention
the word about
um the constitution a lot of it is
mandatory it is a way to ensure the
business of the council is conducted
efficiently and effectively
and also can you also state that the
chairman's ruling on the constitution
should not be challenged it's rule 23 i
think
that the interpretation of the
constitution and how it is applied
is in the gift of the chairman of the
council because it is effectively
his constitution that's absolutely right
um counselor channel um if you go to
paragraph
nine of my report uh page eight and page
well in fact the top of page nine
you'll see i cite rule 23
um in my report
and that explicitly says that his
decision
um in relation to rules shall be final
there is no appeal against the
chairman's decision
yes i just wanted to draw that out thank
you
anybody else chancellor stamp
yes please chairman thank you thank
thank you for that
council channel as well um i actually do
have an issue
um with that anyway what you've just
raised but that's by the by
um simon quelch would you mind asking
are we actually
uh referring all your points to our
constitution
and um code of conduct or are we
including the human rights act
because it states quite clearly that um
you are to allow freedom of speech and
it's unfortunate at the moment that we
have
decided to exclude councillor morris but
that was purely because
the meeting was not allowed to be
progressing because
of the way uh it was being handled and
what he was saying
but what are we looking at this under
the code of conduct his his or any
cancer's right to speak
and i will just justify that and back
that up before you actually speak if
that's all right mr quelch because
if you actually look at the transcript
which is appendix 1
i'll be quite honest here whether i'm
controversial or not
and whether i get into trouble i do
apologize it's not meant to be offensive
i found it quite tip for tat and i also
found it
that counselor morris was not rude to
the chairman
i accept that you know he shouldn't
maybe have carried on
but he does have a right to speak and
you know
okay he's not everybody's cup of tea the
way he speaks and the way he puts things
over mr welch and chairman
but we do have to be careful here and we
do have to look at it
he has never been rude if you read that
transcript i've read it so many times
and you know um councillor um the
ex-chairman turned around at one stage
and said rubbish
about the humans rights act and was
denying the counsellor
his chance to say what he wanted to say
so i actually
haven't made any pre-determinations
before anybody starts to put a report
together or whatever on me
i'm just concerned about that so can you
please in a roundabout way of me
prattling on yet again
are we actually following this under our
code of conduct
that includes the human rights act i
know it was touched on earlier but i
would like
that clearly said for all members
sitting around in
on this committee meeting please mr
quelch
yeah um the article 10
i think is what you're referring to
freedom of expression under the
the the convention
that applies to molden district council
um it it's a public body
uh and therefore the human rights act
applies to it
um so the code of conduct has to be read
um in the light of article 10
there's no doubt about that but when you
read
article 10 it's quite clear to me and i
haven't got it in front of me but i
i've read it a few times in the past
um our article 10
has lots of exceptions to it and
i believe that the localism act
2011 under which this code of conduct
was made because that act as you know
requires
that it's it's mandatory that the local
authority has a code of conduct
um and common to that
common to all local authorities i don't
know an authority that doesn't have
a requirement for respect and
and so i don't believe there's any
conflict between
the code of conduct and article 10 i
believe they're completely
in harmony so the answer to your
question is yes article 10 does apply
but there's nothing in the code of
conduct that conflicts with article 10.
sorry sorry chairman can i just ask
except for stopping freedom of speech if
it's in the wrong place shall we say
well i think this is the very issue that
you have to decide as members isn't it
you have to you have to decide whether
it's legitimate
for a counsellor when you when you have
rules that control how a meeting works
for for that member to disobey those
rules
if you're satisfied as a joint standards
committee that that is legitimate
for a member to um
to choose when he does or
when he doesn't obey those rules then if
you feel that's legitimate then you will
you will find that there is no
disrespect
thank you yeah would you like me to say
any more chairman i mean
i i i would like thank you i'd like to
refer to because we are still dealing
with appendixes um aren't we
uh mr koch if you go to page 28
6-19 or whatever it is i mean the notes
i've written on there um i i've just put
cancer boys sticking up so much for
another counsellor whatever
and and i'm gonna just try and balance
this
because i feel this is a little bit
unbalanced at the moment if you look
further down there
there's a comment and and the previous
chairman
um said that this councillor wasn't
going to be included or he shouldn't be
included and you wouldn't be included if
you look further down morris you've got
a little bit of a
aji barges i would call it um so
i actually feel again like i've just
said
there was a lot of tip for tap the issue
may be the way
that we are looking at it i think from
the moment is whether
whether he's breached uh councillor
morris has breached the code of conduct
by not shutting up
but i have a real issue in the fact that
whether we like it or not whether this
councillor's methods
are acceptable to some or not
he hasn't been allowed to speak properly
just because he does say things you know
and i totally councilor morris i'm sure
you're listening even though you can't
speak
i didn't agree with the way that he was
attacking the monitoring officer
i thought your questions were were you
feeling justified
my personal view was they aren't um but
i think it was very tip-to-toe and i
think some of this is on call
for and some of the language that was
used is inflammatory mr quelch
so i don't i'm sure you can't help me
but i really am
struggling to to to actually
mitigate or balance so i didn't put my
camera on i do apologize
to to balance this thank you chairman
it's not a question it was just a
statement thank you
okay let's find anybody else yes
chairman counselor jarvis and then
councillor bassinger
councillor jarvis please
thank you chairman um i'll listen to
what
council stamp says there and i think my
comments are similar to her so
this is uh we all know um count
uh we all know um the style um
um that councilor morrissey sort of
adopts
uh he is a disruptor he's not very keen
on the rules
and some of us might find that outside
of our comfort zone
but it's also true that you know he's a
representative
and he has a number of points to say and
the fact is
quite a lot of the stuff that he says um
are issues that the council perhaps
needs to listen to
and quite a lot of the stories or
accusations that he's made
have subsequently been found to have
substance so
i do share um uh some
uh sympathy uh with his desire to bring
matters to the attention some very
important matters to the attention of
the council
and i think this is always the slight
problem here with balance because
i think um you know if he could adopt a
style
uh where he brings those matters at the
right time
uh in the right way
he he he would be more effective
in serving his public in getting those
issues
properly considered um but look we're
all different we all have a different
style we can't tell people
to behave in a different way so i think
i mean with regards to section 11 of the
report
which we're talking about i think i've
heard that
monitoring officer has said that he
sensed chrissy morris uh
uh he didn't sense that he was aware of
his responsibilities well i'd like to
listen
as we've got councillor morris here when
he's allowed back in
i'd just like to hear from him if that's
okay if he is aware of his
responsibilities
as a counselor directly from him if
that's okay chairman
let's just hear what he has to say and
um
i think uh my only other point if i made
chairman is that i notice
um i notice that there are a number of
sanctions that are obviously in this
report i'm not sure if we're talking
about the sanctions yet
but if they're obviously contained
within the report we're talking about
the whole report
um if we are then i just wondered if the
monitoring officer could comment as to
look um how effective he thinks most of
those sanctions
are going to be you know essentia on
chrissy morris a written apology
um you know um coming off a few
committees
um you know i just i'm trying to get to
how we can actually
make the most of and get the best out of
councillor morris you know it'd be
really good if um if we could um
come to a sort of understanding i think
so he can contribute which i think he
can
enormously to the council but he does
have to respect
obviously the rules of the council as
well so i think when the opportunity is
there i'd like to hear
chairman from christie morris about his
view
on his responsibilities as a councillor
and acting within
the democracy of the council and its
constitution chairman thank you
thank you thank you well i know anybody
else
yes chairman counselor
[Music]
where are we mr chairman it's you now
cancer
passenger thank you i i would just like
to to clarify
um being as the chairman at um at this
meeting
um hasn't made the complaint i would
just like to point out that councillor
dewitt was the main complaint
at the last joint status meeting as he
is at this one
and again i just feel that um
perhaps he's being a little
oversensitive and
i don't really understand why he's the
only one that seems to have made the
complaint
apart from obviously the person the
outside person
thank you for that anybody else
um not at the moment chairman not with a
question oh cancer channel would like to
come back channel
um thank you chairman um i just like to
say i do agree with
quite a bit that counselor jarvis has
said there
and i think the issue is chairman and i
guess it is about
and the reason i had to go with your
request to be no longer heard because as
i was i made my case quite clear the
assurances
and i think that's quite important is
about the process and actually
if we all did or i know we all have
different ways but
if we all acted in that way constantly
spoke all at the same time
the chairman and the meeting of the
business could not progress
uh progress it would just be total
fallout and i think that's what
we sort of concentrate on and i'm sure
council and morris going forward i know
this morning's meeting what had to occur
and everything but it is about
wanting to say your piece but saying
probably at the right time
in the right manner and not speaking
over necessarily the chairman and i know
that council morrisville is the chairman
spoke after him
and that was pointed out in the report
and that's why he feels he was the
if you like the victim of the scene and
why the meeting was closed down nothing
to do with him but the chairman
but we couldn't all act in that same way
otherwise we wouldn't be able to
progress the business chairman
so i'm sure if you do permit counselor
morris to come back
because i think it might be useful to
hear um
in respect of the responsibilities his
take on that
chairman thank you very counselor
channel
i will ask simon first to read out the
independent person's report please and
then i'll ask
um christy morris councillor morris to
come back
okay i'll invite him back into the
meeting
um yeah thank you chairman uh this is a
um email from norman hodgson uh on the
1st
of september um he says
that he was unable to attend this
meeting
um and he in respect of the complaint
made by councillor
dueck one as per the report
i agree with the investigator councilor
morris did not
contravene the code of conduct in
relation to his conduct at the overview
and scrutiny scrutiny meeting
two as per events at the october and
november council meetings
from the information provided and given
that i am
not entirely sure of the procedure it is
somewhat difficult for me to determine
what went on at these meetings
certain concerns were expressed by
councillor morris that he should be
allowed to speak
and the chairman did allow a recorded
vote on one occasion which was only won
by one vote
this seemingly indicates that a good
many of the councils were prepared for
him to carry on
interrupting this particular meeting the
investigator has clearly explained the
council's own rules of council behavior
which counselor morris appeared to flout
on a number of occasions
at both meetings of the council
therefore in my view
council morris did contribute did
contravene the code of conduct at both
the october
and november meetings i would agree that
it could recently determine that he did
bring the office of counsellor
and that of the council into disrepute
thank you for that simon um councillor
morris can you switch him back on to
come but please comment on the
facts of this not other things
i'm happy microphone working all the
time
just to prove that i can sit on my hands
when i need to well done councillor
maurice i respect you for that
thank you thank you
fully in our fight chairman um
councillor mays would like to ask a
question before we move on to the next
stage
council mays would you like to ask a
question of somebody
uh yes thank you um
it's really um i'm just in relation to
the
uh email that um mr quelch has just read
out
uh which i've only just seen i didn't
see it attached to the original
email that he sent out so i apologize
for that um
it's quite interesting um
i i think that um we are not as members
we are not so much concerned with the
interrupting that goes on because we do
actually want to hear
publicly what councilman morrison has to
say
however i do feel that sometimes we need
to have that in a much more concise
manner
um and maybe as councillor jarvis
pointed out
um we need to try and find a way to work
forward
with that and deal with some of the
aspects that are being brought to our
attention
this is important for the the reputation
which is absolutely paramount of this
council
and we need to build on that thank you
mr chairman
thank you very much for your kind words
right where do we go next um
pastor morris do you want to say
anything yeah
i've got plenty
you're interrupting you've not asked to
speak or anything you've interrupted me
you've not done what the uh
chairman has requested okay is this
frozen
right so michael what i would suggest
i don't get in any trouble is that i
would like to field
any questions from any counsellor or
any officer in fact anyone that's got a
question
i'm open all this okay has anyone got
any questions please
yes please counselor was that counselor
yes well really i i thought
what was agreed council jarvis spoke
i came in and council jarvis said he'd
be interested here council morris's
views about
the responsibilities and like to hear
from him
and i thought that's what i uh agreed as
well i thought that's what you said
chairman you'd ask him to come back in
to give councillor morris the
opportunity
to um speak regarding the point council
of jarvis made
would you like the opportunity to answer
questions
ask the questions as i understood it
so i'm here saying has anyone got any
questions
counselor channel if you've got a
question please pose it
well i'll frame what counselor jarvis
put then in a question regarding your
responsibilities
how do you see your how do you how do
you understand your responsibilities
you may understand your rights but want
to hear from you the understanding of
your responsibilities as a counsellor
when we're in the chamber etcetera and
regarding the constitution
abilities is to uphold the nolan
principles
my responsibilities are to the people
that voted for me
to the community and to the vulnerable
people that were being bullied at morton
district council
i am disgusted that only a handful of
councillors
decided to actually uh
help me with the bullying culture that
was perpetrated
throughout morgan district council all
of our councillors
knew what was going on very few of us
including you and stood up you didn't
stand up penny
we have seen um bullying
go on in its council for years and no
one has done
anything about it i know better run
burger
bands than morgan district council
it was terrible everyone almost everyone
ignored it and we should of all
collectively um
rooted it out and it was left to me to
do
i was the one at the front i was helped
by certain other counsellors but
every single counselor has a moral
responsibility
and there you go there's your
responsibility quote to stand up
to wrongdoing and the chairman of the
former chairman
bob boyce was part of the bullying
culture
along with the chairman of this jsc mr
helms
along with thompson who an excuse my
french
has admitted to calling her own counsel
as bastards
in in a public meeting something
so responsibilities my responsibility
i'll stop standing weirdo
um my responsibility
my responsibilities are to the people
and to the truth
is all i've done is tell the truth
everything i
said has proven to be correct the last
joint standards
um meeting where we all found fluka to
be
a homophobic bully that's threatened
women in the chamber
has did
being bullied my responsibilities are to
the people being bullied
and to the truth i'm sorry if
you if my ugly truth offends your
beautiful life but what i said
was a fact it needed to be exposed and
it needed to be challenged
councillor morris councillor morris
chairman can i come in councillor morris
would you be able to listen to what
councillor jarvis said and
actually allow him to speak now would
would that be acceptable to you because
councillor jarvis spoke a great deal of
sense counselor morris
chairman is that okay with you too it's
okay with me
because councillor morris is trying
again
[Music]
uh i think uh as i was saying earlier i
was keen to hear what you had to say
i think you know i would describe you as
a disrupter and i mean that as a
compliment
because sometimes in
in councils in any organization you need
people who are going to make change
happen
and i do think you bring that to the
council you know that that's my view on
that
but it's really a question of you
achieving a balance if you can as well
as wanting to achieve that
and bring matters to people's attention
and get justice and rights
to happen and to expose issues that are
wrong
and you do that very well obviously for
us to function as an effective council
there are rules so that we can do that
so we're not all talking at once
so that somebody can steer a meeting not
i just appeal to you to try and operate
if you can
within those uh guidelines that we set
and those guidelines are there to ensure
that we can all serve the people we've
been elected to serve
you know that's right it's not just you
serving people we're serving people too
so if you can i'd appeal to you to sort
of temper that
natural enthusiasm and energy which i
admire
uh if you can temper that i think you'll
be amazed what
you and the council as a whole can then
achieve and i just appeal to you on that
basis
counsellor jarvis thank you very much
as you know i've got great respect for
you i do believe that you
are a excellent counsellor uh you're one
of the few councillors that's worked for
rob
in this uh in this district um what i
would say mate is that my thoughts make
me perfect
for my purpose um i make no
apology for the way i present things i
do them
the best i can sometimes i'm course
sometimes i'm stubborn but sometimes
that
is the course of action that is needed
i understand what you're saying about um
doing things a different way
but as you will all be aware for the
first six months
of um getting into the district council
is all i've done was sit there on my
hands
i didn't say brutal goose i watched
councillors
and excuse my french i saw councilman
saying [ __ ] totter
to uh officers in the chamber and they
ain't here
um various stuff like that but i didn't
i never
had and still don't want to burn it down
i simply want to make it right
now i tried i appealed to
on a personal level on an informal level
to all the people that i could
i tried and i was ignored and laughed at
so i was left with very very few options
but to do things the way i've done
you might not like my methods but you
cannot argue
with the results um
we should have dealt with this months
ago and it shouldn't have had to come
out like this to the public
to to to make the reputation of the
council
even worse not enough and you
councillor jarvis were excellent i've
gotta say
yourself and a few other councillors
were very good
um but the the majority of councillors
did
absolutely nothing to try and address
the issues
and quite simply the um
sorry quite simply the
um so i've lost my training fault on
that one quite simply
no one did enough
all right look i've heard what you've
got to say but you've seen already from
this morning
you've seen from things that have
happened in recent times
changes upon us things are happening
they're not happening as quickly as you
would like
they're not happening as quickly as a
lot of people would like
but they are happening so i think if you
can uh
be a little patient uh work with people
other people who want to achieve a lot
of the changes you want to achieve
you will find that that's an effective
way
we as a council we have to have some
rules and regulations
it sounds boring but we have to have it
so everybody can have their say
i saw i'm just appealing to you look you
know change is happening
if you can just work with us uh over the
next few months i think you will be
amazed how much can be achieved
and that that's an honest appeal to you
well said i said that i appreciate that
and i totally take that on the ball
i'll take that one completely onto you
the trouble i've got
is that when i uh you know when i'm
sitting here being personally attacked
by the people
that didn't stand up for the you know
against the bullying that is my rob
i have got a problem with officers and
other councillors
lying about what's going on if this
council
spent as much time
okay okay let's see if we can try and
stick with today's program
yes please get through
what makes you laugh all right
i'm not thankful for your thing that
makes you laugh okay
thank you guys i couldn't hear that
sorry morris said he was a bit broken
i said what i said councillor channel
was i'm not bothered by councillor
helms's
scorn because i've seen what makes him
laugh
okay let's let's move on chairman
councillor none would like to anyone any
other questions
please counseling
thank you um
thank you chip well no i don't have any
questions
tomorrow so i have a proposition to make
okay would you like to make the
proposition please
yes thank you very much um so having
read the report and listened to the
evidence very carefully and
uh the eloquent comments of councillor
jarvis
my feelings are that the
november mr
morris issue should never have been
brought to us
uh and therefore i i agree that the code
has not been breached
because uh mr morris was acting as a
member of the general public
and as far as the second element's
concerned which the october and november
uh concerns um i think like councillor
morris
was very close to the mark however
the we are living through and have lived
through difficult times
as illustrated by this morning's uh
hearing
and on that basis i did not believe
at this stage with half of the evidence
before as the first report
okay right berna can we go to the vote
please
can we just check council maze had asked
to ask a question as well are you
oh uh yeah yes uh yes mr chairman
the only thing i wanted to draw members
attention to
was in um the european convention on
human rights
um paragraph 10 10
no sorry i think it's 12 g
says politicians are required to have a
thick skin i mean not that thick
you know we do have to have some
sensitive sides um and be tolerant of
criticism
and adverse comment uh it then goes on
to say and i think that um councillor
morris as
uh councilman has pointed out um this
falls very much
into that field um and
hence i have supported councillor nuns
proposal
okay thank you very much for that i'll
take it i have a sick skin as well
right we'll move on to the vote
chairman do we not debate it like we did
again this morning after the proposals
i think some members want to debate it
chairman okay if that's the wish
carry on debating it who do you want to
speak first counselor jarvis would like
to speak
that's the job thank you chairman
i think it's uh i think it's just a
proper process isn't it once a motion
has been put and seconded
even if it's a brief opportunity
to debate it um i think uh
as i was saying earlier this really is a
question of balance
uh i think uh i witnessed and i read the
reports
uh uh certainly some disruption
which caused problems it's a fine edge
thing though because
a lot of the points that were made were
very useful
uh and i can understand the frustration
that council
morris has had at the same time you know
i
would love to see and hear some words of
respect with regards to the process
that we all have to adhere to if we're
going to
run an effective council so
i think it's very difficult but i think
i find myself uh wanting to hear and
wanting to
counsel morris to do the good things he
does but i find it
very difficult reading the monitoring
officer's report
and hearing the comments from the
independent officer
i find it very difficult uh not to
come to a conclusion that perhaps
his actions did bring the council uh um
into disrepute because you know
obviously because he
he he he he stopped the process so often
so it's very difficult i think it's a
very finely judged thing
um and uh i think councillors have got a
very difficult
um decision to make uh on a finally
finally judged issue
counselor did you want to say something
yes john
thank you i think councillor jarvis
has you know largely said it all
however um having done the training and
everything and you're asked to look at
the evidence
and obviously um i've seen councillor
dwight's letter however what i've been
concentrating on
is the report of the monitoring officer
and his assessment of it all and the
facts he's laid out clearly
and also his conclusion what he feels
um and also of course um we have to
have here the views of the independent
person which we have as well
and he was quite clear um i do agree
regarding
um the complaint regarding which was
related to the november opium scrutiny
um yeah that re i agree with council and
none that actually because
councillor morris was it was quite clear
he was called mr morris you allowed him
to speak
i think you were in the chair at the
time actually uh council helm
and you allowed him as a member of the
public
so therefore i think that one's aside so
i'm going now on the meetings of the
council
of october and november i've read the
report of the monitoring officer
i see the evidence um that is within
there if you like in the assessment by
the monitoring officer
we've asked questions of the monitoring
officer he's answered them
norman hodgson's email was quite clear
and specific
and both really uh show the same
conclusion chairman
so i have to go with the evidence um
presented and conclusions drawn
by persons that are experienced in this
far so
more so than i am
thank you councillor anybody else yes
chairman cassidy stamp would like to
speak
that's the stamp please oh yeah thank
you chairman
um i want to refer back just before we
move on to the vote
to the email from councillor dewick and
the bot the second to bottom paragraph
when he actually says this boorish
behavior
i believe is deliberate councillor
morris clearly has no respect for the
democratic authority of malden district
council
he has no respect for the chairman of
malden district council
nor for its members and officers well i
actually don't agree with that
i think councillor morris shows a great
deal of respect to
uh officers uh and members if they show
him respect too
i've only known councillor morris since
he was elected
and i am going to speak as i find he has
always been respectful to me
he has never disrespected me no matter
what views different views we've had
and and i know it's difficult when
you're chairing a meeting chairman when
there's a difficult
counsellor or a member of the public
giving you grief totally take that on
board
and that's the area of concern i have
before i haven't still haven't decided
i'm going to vote
but i i that's the area of concern i
have and councillor chana and jarvis is
quite correct
to say that we all have to work under
the rules
saying that i refer to what i said
previously if you read the transcript
counselor morris wasn't shown respect
and he gave the
respect lack of respect back to the
chairman at the time
i'm not saying two rights make her wrong
because i was always taught that from
being from the north two rights don't
make her wrong
but i do think we have to look at this
in the context and we've also got to
look at this in the treatment
and it is relevant chairman the
treatment we've all
was given when we was elected as
independents
in may 2019 and i think we have to take
into account
that i mean i was surprised chairman
that these two complaints
definitely well three complaints was all
huddled together i personally think
the first complaint should have come to
the cat to the standards committee
the second one should have come it's
like saying oh i'm gonna it's like
husbands and wife's relationship
oh i'm gonna hold that against you and
whenever i'm gonna absolutely throw at
you
i don't think that's the way this
council should operate i think if there
was a complaint
it should have been made it should have
been assessed and it should have been
brought to committee
or non-committee whatever the decision
had been made but to me
to put them all together and say oh you
have been a naughty boy because we put
them all together
i'm sorry i actually don't agree with
and as i've said
i still haven't made my mind up but i
have had
councillor morris has never ever
disrespected me
and i have actually had compliments from
his uh
residence where he works he works really
hard where he actually is
as a town councillor so i mean come on
there is a balance here
don't forget chairman i think i've still
got a minute left uh
that when we came into uh the
independence we were disallowed and we
were not allowed to take part in
anything
now can you imagine all the conservative
councillors
being excluded because you've been in
power for 28 years chairman
how you would feel it's not nice so i
think there's been a build up here
and i feel personally um you know
i think i'm a fair person i think
there's mitigation
and that's why i still haven't made my
mind up and thank you chairman for
allowing me to speak
that's fine cancer stamp no problem at
all
yes chairman councillor morris would
like to ask a question and then cancel
channel okay councillor morris
ladies first place to chair cast the
channel please
stamp now is referred subscribe lumping
all these um uh
compliance together so can i just be
clear chairman we have got the other
complaint from the member of the public
are we taking that separately and
judging
and judging
we do something on this one to say what
we feel and then there'll be
a discussion on that other one and then
we have a again
an issue on whether you know breach or
not on that one they'll get gonna be
two separate breaches i would like two
separate
uh separate meetings is that all right
simon
if it's not chairman it's lumped
together really you're at the same joint
standards hearing chairman no matter how
you want to dress it
up well we haven't discussed the member
of the public that's what i'm saying
we're coming on to that after this are
we so we're doing a vote on this one and
then we'll move to the member of the
public and vote on that so there could
be
two or not situations simon can i have
advice from you whether we put it all
together or do one at a time
you you have two separate complaint
letters
dealing with completely different
meetings
and you have two separate investigations
the fact that they happen to be in the
same committee meeting
doesn't mean to say that they are not
separate investigations
chairman can i ask how often this has
happened before please just for a matter
of clarity
how many times have you had this happen
before where this
this two separate or three separate
things have been held at the same jsc
committee
i haven't had this before and i was
thrusted to this meeting without any
prior warning
so i'd have to ask simon whether this
happened before
i've never had complaints against the
councillor in such quick succession so
yeah it's never happened before but i've
never been in a situation
i think furthermore as i've just
explained
the first matter was going to be brought
on its own in february
that had to be cancelled um
i tried to bring it as quickly as i
could um
but that wasn't possible i tried then to
bring it in march
the government then closed everything
down
and members decided they weren't going
to have any meetings that wasn't my
decision that was members decision
um and so i tried to bring it to img
and they were they they were unprepared
to deal with it
so initially this should have been dealt
with on its own
the first report in february now i could
have brought
separate jscs but they relate to
similar behavior even though they're
separate investigations
and it would have meant that council and
morris would have had to have attended
to counseling this seems to me to be
the most efficient way that's my view
and maybe members
feel otherwise um
i don't know what else i can say really
i i'm so i don't understand what the
problem is
chairman can i come back to try and
clarify what the problem may be
thank you the problem is that if the
first complaint had
of been heard and if the uh counsellor
had had any sanctions
like suggested training like whatever we
may not have come to the second
complaint
so while the monitoring officer has
stated his case very clearly and
eloquently and fine i don't have a
problem with that
i do have a problem that i i still say
if you'd have been get found guilty
whatever you want to say
it would have been dealt with whereas i
feel lumping them both together
you've already got the thing if if the
counselor gets found um to breach the
code of conduct
they're going to think oh well his
behaviors continue
i don't think that we have given
councillors support
training time etc etc
and i do feel that's mitigated and i
take on board what counselor chan has
said she's absolutely right
and thank you for pointing it out i did
actually say that at the very beginning
it was i knew it was going to be did sep
conducted separately but i was there to
make a point thank you
right members what do you want to do do
you want them separately all in one
proposal please chairman constant nun
would like to come back
i propose yes thank you chairman
just to be absolutely clear uh my
seconded proposition relates to
uh appendix one the
first report uh that's that was my
proposition
for the third quarter the first report
only
okay so chairman come in
yes you may because i think the
monitoring officer
i think the monitoring office has made
it very clear that this is the
the first complaint if you like there's
the ovarian scrutiny and there are
council meetings of november and october
then we so we deal with that and then
the second investigation
is to do with the complaint from the
member of the public and we deal with
that
so from what i'm hearing and what
council anand has just clarified and
made clear as well
this is only to do with the first report
which mr quelch took us through
relating to opium scrutiny and november
and
um november and october council meetings
and then we move on
when that votes taken to consider the
complaint made by the member of the
public and the investigation
they're in that then followed thank you
for that counselor channel that's what i
intended to do but people put doubt in
my mind
so has everyone finished discussion on
this
and can we move to the vote or does
anyone want to say any more
i did ask to speak yes you may
um i would just like to remind everyone
that
my concerns that i tried to bring up
informally
and through other avenues were rejected
were ignored
so the only thing i had left to do
was to bring them to full council
and to everyone's attention because i
was being ignored
thank you very much i'm not finished
i've not finished i've not finished if
i was listened to an earlier stage and
if more people
would have taken on board the concerns
and the proven
acts of a select new uh councillors you
being one of those councillors
michael then this wouldn't have happened
i did what i had to do and i make no
apology for that
maybe next time hopefully there won't be
a next time
i won't have to do that way because we
collectively
will do it this is politically motivated
and political loyalty shouldn't come
into it
we should be looking at this morally and
morally
what has happened with fluker and the
fluka riots was abhorrent and shouldn't
have happened
it means that if i have to do this then
that's fine i'll do it
again but my responsibility is too
true okay thank you very much council
morris
are we ready to go to the vote
yes councillor uh um
can you go to the vote please do you
want it recorded anybody yes
can we just have that clear again
chairman what lenon's proposal was
can you read out the proposal please in
the second
council of nun can you put your proposal
again please
oh i'm sorry chair i thought you were
talking too
um yes my proposal uh
is that um the first element of the
complaint
relating to uh mr morris
should never have been brought to us in
the first place
because it's not a breach code and we're
here primarily to look at breaches of
the code
the second element i believe that
councillor morris
was very close to the mark but it was a
heated debate
in the context of very difficult times
with this district council
as demonstrated by this morning's joint
standards
capital and therefore my conclusion
is that councilman boris has not failed
to comply with the member's code
is there any other proposals before we
go to the vote um i'd like to second
that proposal
yes you did earlier on councillor thank
you
right berna can you go to the vote then
please
and there was a call for a recorded vote
has that been seconded
thank you very much councillors i will
call you in alphabetical order can you
speak
clearly in state
thank you chairman um i agree with the
opium scrutiny issue but i have to go
with the monitoring officer's report
and the advice of the independent person
so i have to go
against the constitution caster helm i'm
afraid i've got to go
against the recommendation
council jarvis
thank you um well it's a very difficult
decision
um i'm actually going to go for the
motion i've listened to all the debate
i'm actually going to go for i just hope
for a better future
thank you council jarvis caster keys
four customize
four counts to none
four stamp
four thank you members that's six
four two against no abstentions
thank you chairman okay that's uh
julie carried that councilor morris has
not breached the code of conduct
uh simon can we now go to
the committee councillors please
thank you to the committee and the
councillors
okay thank you right we'll move on to
the second complaint
uh simon would you like to present the
second complaint
uh yes this is the report of stuart
jennings deputy monitoring officer
it's a complaint by a member of the
public um thomas kelly
um i can read that out now if members
want to explain
yes um
uh it's to the monitoring officers dated
the 14th
of february this year there's a formal
complaint against
councillor morris you will have been
aware that i attended full
council to put forward two questions
this
is a complaint based on circumstances
arising at that meeting
one being accosted by the name
counsellor after i put forward my
questions
two the disrespect shown to the chairman
three aggressive behavior the chairman
of a committee
finance i believe councillor harker four
taking making mobile telephone calls
during the meeting
five disrespectful wearing of a cap six
actions which would bring the council
into disrepute
had the press been present should
mdc fail to take punitive action against
the name
the main the named member then i give
notice that the ineffectiveness
of um procedure policies
will be a matter of complaint to the
responsible government department
i will also make my views and criticisms
made known
via local press uh yours faithfully
thomas kelly
there was also and this was mentioned by
mr
um jennings there was also another
member of the public that made a
complaint but that person wished
to be mr remain anonymous mr jennings
mentions that
in his report um at
page 44 1.11
although he says he hasn't taken that
particular complaint into account but he
wanted the committee
to know uh that there was a second
complaint as well
um members there it is i mean i
it's not my report it is mr um mr
jennings report
um the matters related to
a exchange between the
uh chairman and also
uh councillor morris at the end of a
meeting in february the 13th of february
um at 1.4
mr jennings interviewed mr kelly
and he explained what he meant by the
words accosted
he speaks about um
uh he talks about um the
disgust that mr kelly talks about
disgusted he felt that what he witnessed
um he considered mr kelly thought that
at 1.4
that the behavior of counsellor morris
showed utter contempt for the council as
a regulatory body
um
then i think that there was a discussion
after this report was
written and to be fair to councillor
morris there wasn't a lot of time
between
the writing of this report and
um seeking council morris's views
that is true um after this report was
written
mr jennings in my presence was able to
speak to councillor morris
about the allegations um
that counselor morris said changed his
view
on the report um and so here it
is his conclusion is um
that 1.14 page 44
that there was a breach of the provision
of the code of conduct um
3.2 not showing respect
and 3.5 bringing the authority
or his office into disrepute
now chairman do you want me to read the
um do you want me to read the
[Music]
independent offices view person's view
or do you want to leave that until later
we'll do that now then uh councillor
morris can question that as well
okay chairman can i ask that the emails
read out again from the complainant
please j it's only a small one but can
we have that before you move on mr
quelch is that okay
i i can do that yes i can do that
i think we heard it all last time did we
no
thank you i didn't thank you i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i i read it probably too quickly um
okay it's it's to me it's from
uh thomas kelly it's dated the 14th
of and if members aren't hearing me or
thinking that i'm
reading too quickly please stop me 14th
of february 2020 dear sir
formal complaint against molten district
councillor
morris you will have been aware that i
attended full council to put forward two
questions
this is a complaint based on
circumstances arising
at that meeting
one being accosted by the name
counsellor after i have put forward my
questions
two the disrespect shown to the chairman
three aggressive behavior to the
chairman of the of
of a committee and it's in brackets
finance
i believe councillor harker close
brackets
4. taking making mobile telephone calls
during the meeting
5. disrespectful wearing of a cap
six actions which will bring the council
into disrepute
had press been present
should mdc fail to take punitive action
against the name member
then i give notice that the
ineffectiveness of
um procedure policies will be
a matter of complaint to the responsible
government department
i will also make my views and criticisms
made known
via local press yours faithfully thomas
kelly he's a resident in molden
chairman my declare an interest actually
um
but bearing in mind uh council of
marcy's questionings of simon quelch
i will declare um i've known mr kelly a
very long time
he was indeed both a town councillor and
a malden district council at one time
both
i have to say um i think on our council
as a conservative at one point but also
as an independent
and i do have some dealings with mr
kelly because he
is in my he lives in my um essex county
council division of malden
and so he does approach me on matters to
do with
highways footpaths and parking and other
such things to do with
any well matters that a resident would
ordinarily come to
their elected representative on chairman
thank you very much anybody else
i will declare that i've known um
counselor kel ex counselor kelly tom
kelly
when i was previously a council about
12 years ago but i've had no contact
with him since
thank you right i now invite councillor
morris to ask
any questions of clarification that he
may have
of the monastery
sorry chairman and counselor nun and
cancer stamp had just had some questions
before we moved to that point
sorry i didn't see that counsellor none
and counselor
that's fine sorry
steven nunn councillor none thank you
very much chairman
um yes can i too please declare that
um i am acquainted with mr kelly
uh non-petuniary
as far as that's concerned i have two
questions
to ask of mr quelch please
the first question relates to 1.4
mr kenny's use of the word accosted
um if you look at the dictionary
definition for the word accosted
it means to go up to or to speak to
somebody
in a threatening way now
um the monitoring officer has said
that's been clarified at 1.4 the use of
the word accosted
but unless i'm being particularly thick
here
um i don't think it has been clarified
before
so i my first question is to ask him
where where is the clarification please
as counselor nun knows that's not my
report i didn't do the investigation
but at 1.4 um
mr jennings had spoken to mr kelly
uh and asked him to clarify that very
point that you've asked about and mr
kelly said that he was taken aback by
the
intervention of councillor morris
appearing to be aimed at him
in other words himself um asking his
questions and receiving reply so it
appears to me
that the reference to the word accosting
here
um is meant by mr kelly to mean
that um there was obviously some form
of belief that councilor morris was
aiming questions at him in obviously a
way he didn't like
okay thank you very much for the
clarification on that to
that particular question my second and
final
question
again you know it may well be that
because my background has been in
hr related investigations
at a loss to know why 1.11 has been
included
what we've got here is um uh the
investigating officer saying
well we did get another complaint but um
it's anonymous and so we're not going to
investigate that but we'll just chuck
that in the bucket as well i mean why
why is that there um well councillor
none
we can withhold information from you if
you want
i don't want
well it was a complaint it was a
complaint
i have the i have the email on file
it was a member of the public um
who attended the meeting but he um
for his own reasons it was a he for his
own reasons
um did not want uh
his identity to be disclosed
mr jennings has i mean he could have not
put that in
but it's as a matter of record that
information
is there um he's mr jennings has very
fairly says he hasn't based his
investigation
on that email but he obviously felt
that you as members should know that
mr kelly was not alone in his um concern
now you can dismiss that that is a
matter for you
but without telling you the information
um you wouldn't have the right to
dismiss it if you wanted to
well i i respect your interpretation of
that
um
okay um would you like me to read it
without disclosing the name
okay should i do that chairman
yes please okay this is
an email dated the 14th of february
um 2020 it's to me
it's called private and confidential
sorry why are you getting point of order
because it's got nothing to do with a
complaint you've got a you've got
a uh somewhat you've got an anonymous
complaint coming it could be
anyone it could be vexatious frivolous
or anything
well that that is my point you know i
see it as double jeopardy
as i did this morning um uh
when i when we were having just kept a
similar discussion
so to put in a report that oh by the way
i had another complaint but they don't
want to actually be named and pursued
that
i i haven't got a clue what it's about
and and i think
that as a as a committee we should
discount such
such inclusions and we should focus on
the evidence that's been presented
members are you happy to
nullify this uh complaint or what would
you like to do
german can i make a proposal yes please
by all means
was there another person who said the
same thing
sorry can i make a proposal that we um
strike to remove 1.11 off appendix 2
and it plays no part in our i mean i did
the same as canceller
none i've put question mark stars
irrelevant
so i totally agree with what councillor
um
nun has said so can i propose chairman
from the record second place
okay can i just say something i mean i
haven't even thought about it like that
because i read the last sentence which
made it clear
his investigation has been confined to
the complaints of mr kelly so that's all
i've looked at
in terms of i realize that as well but
people want to bring something into it
so
chairman i don't think that's very fair
people don't want to bring anything into
it we're trying to actually ascertain
the facts that is written down
in appendix 2 chairman you have a report
in front if you've read it it's
discounted at the end of that report
exactly
exactly it's been discounted for
chairman with all due respect
you just tried to diss that by your
comment that's that's not right
so chairman yes the point i was making
was that it doesn't need to be in the
report
and if we don't if if it's not a formal
complaint
and we don't know who's complaining or
what they're saying and there's no
evidence
and surely in terms of natural justice
you don't produce a report that says oh
by the way i've had loads of other
people saying the same thing but i can't
tell you who they are
you just don't do that
thank you for that council line it's
been discounted now anyway and it was in
the report
so where do you want to go with this
there was a proposal
i've done if it was second to none
right okay i know the second did that
now
good gentleman can stand proposed as
encountering non-secondary
yes please to discount
the section okay remember i will call
you in alphabetical order
um can you please indicate
for against abstain
just bear with me for a moment please
well chairman i wasn't paying any
credence or weight to it whatsoever but
to keep everyone happy i'll save four if
people want it struck out
i've struck it out immediately having
read the paragraph on the last sentence
answer helm i had also discounted that
then it's in the end of the report so
i'll vote for as well please
mr jarvis i'm four with no hesitation
i think it is relevant that it was in
there and it shouldn't be because it
tends to lend weight to an argument
um whereas if it hadn't been there it
wouldn't have lent any weight so i don't
think it should have been in there
i'm definitely for that it should be
struck out not considered or given any
weight whatsoever
thank you cancer keys
council jarvis has just took the word
straight out of my mouth four
councillor maze four
none four
stamp four thank you members that's
eight for
none against no obstacles thank you that
that's taken out of the report now
um where are we now members yes
chairman we still have some members
wishing to speak please i think i don't
know if cancer stamp has covered all her
points
she was just next then counselor channel
and counselor peter stills okay
no no chairman i'll i will reserve the
right to come back after the debate if
that's okay thank you chair
okay
uh thank you question for the monitoring
officer really i know
it's um he didn't do the investigation
it's the deputy money trucks so but
obviously
he's presented it in his he's here to
answer questions
and it's to do with uh chairman um on
the on the report with the deputy
monitoring officer
found on page 44 and it relates to
0.12 and it's the conclusion chairman
and it
the last paragraph of that conclusion in
1.12 it says
in the subsequent exchange with the
chairman the assertion by council
morris that the chairman was too old and
needed to quit was equally disrespectful
and offensive
in terms of equality's legislation
however my question is this
then it's silent at the end on that
because we do under the code of conduct
have under 3a
i think i think it's 3 8 about really we
have to ensure we're not
going against the equality's enactment
um
obviously because age is a protected
characteristic
um and so i do ask that question
so the fact is it's raised by the deputy
monitoring officer
but then he just says about
disrespectful and offensive in terms of
the quality's legislation he then
he makes no reference regarding the code
of conduct where i think 3a applies
but also i know that the actually the
complainant didn't make reference to
that
so should there be any weight applied
to the last paragraph of that um
you know uh conclusion that the deputy
monitoring office put in his baby to
comment having listened
to the obviously the tape or whatever um
so that's my question really what weight
should be applied bearing in mind the
complainant didn't mention it
the deputy monitoring officer
investigated does and mentions that it's
disrespectful and offensive
and then we have a code of conduct which
mentions 3a about
equality's enactment and i was i suppose
i was a bit surprised that
councillor morris had said that because
i'm aware of councillor morris
is well um in fact i i am aware how he
does
um how can i put this stand up for
various elements
of um of persons with certain protected
characteristics let's put it that way
simon can you answer that question
please yeah i think that mr
jennings is mentioning it because it
goes to the disrespect point
and i think that's how he puts it
to them make the personal remarkets to
the german being too old and needing to
quit was equally disrespectful that's
the way he puts it
as well as offending the equality's
legislation i think this point was
raised this morning
that unless the particular i don't think
myself there is a breach of that part
of the code in relation to the
equalities legislation simply because
although the remark was um in mr
jennings view disrespectful to the
chairman
it didn't go towards an action in terms
of say for example
um whether someone did or didn't get a
position
i mean it is true to say that uh
councilor morris says you're you're
being too old and you need to quit
you could say you could argue that was
in breach of the code because he was
actually saying because of your age you
need to stand down from being a chairman
you need to
to retire from being a chairman on
grounds of age
but personally i don't think you can
argue that an action
was there
for for the local authority to actually
act contrary to the equality's
legislation so
i think it should only go as mr jennings
put it should only go to the issue of
whether
there was a failure to show respect
thank you for that simon anybody else
thank you
nobody else right we're now two months
chairman cancer stills question
thank you um when i became accounts for
2006
mr kelly was then a town councillor
um he then stopped on the next election
he attended when i was the mayor and
also one of those chairman affairs
committees
as time's gone on he's got very fiery
and very picky on things
to say some object to someone wearing a
cap he could be wearing a cat through
religious reasons um medical reasons
or cultural reasons um
also he very often he'd like to include
blackmail
as he did in his letter i will report
this i will do that i will do that
we actually had him at one meeting as a
member of the public starting to go and
damage cars that he thought was in
uh improperly parked so his left
complaint all right value to make a
complaint but he's very much
in people's face when he gets something
under his skin
so i do not carry any weight with his
letter because i found it threatening
objective and also very typical of his
actions nowadays as he got older
thank you thank you for that we've got
another one please shall we
uh we've got another question
uh yeah mr yes
i believe that's the stamp please i
think it's councillor maze burner i'm
going to come in there at the end
that's the maize then please oh yeah
thank you mr chairman
um yeah from the letter i was very
concerned with the fact
as uh councillor stilts has just picked
up the threatening tone
um you know basically if we don't do
what he wants us to do then
um you know we're going to get reported
anyway
um i don't know this gentleman although
i have come across his name and i've
heard
information but i don't know the
gentleman but i would like to bring you
back to
um you know part g as i did
before on the european convention on
human rights which was politicians are
required to have thick skin
and i think the fact that uh councillor
boyce did not
further his uh complaint actually does
give quite a lot of weight to that
that yeah he he's very well aware that
things will be said in the heat of a
debate um and it has been extremely
lively
over those first few months uh in fact
for the first 12 months um it was very
very lively
um so i'm not entirely sure that i also
give much weight
to this letter um from
from the information that i've also
heard today
thank you uh council stamp wasn't it
yeah yes please chairman um yeah i also
um totally agree with what the previous
councillors have said
um disrespectful wearing a cap sorry you
know it's like saying you're
disrespectful you don't like the color
of
colour of my hair it's totally relevant
it doesn't add to anything
and taking mobile telephone calls during
the meeting
now i know i think you're going to pull
me up and say well it's different now
councillor stamp
when you attend these meetings online
i've seen
the leader the ex-note the ex-leader and
the ex-chairman
being on the phone all the time when
they're communicating to the extent i've
had members of the public message me and
say
what the heck is going on wendy they're
all messaging each other all i can hear
is bing bing bing
so we do have to be careful we're not
going to be selective just because it's
councillor morris
loads of people i'm saying i know he
took the call at the meeting and i
totally agree
and i spoke to councillor morris and i
think he would admit this uh
agreed to this when i turned around and
said councilman i don't agree with that
it's your choice i can't tell you what
to do um
but that i would never do it chairman
but that's me
um showing disrespect to the chairman
that's a matter of what we spoke about
earlier
the chairman i've heard the chairman go
back the chairman's even told me to be
quiet
when i've tried to say something because
when i've spoken when he didn't want me
to speak you know i
you know i could have taken offense at
that but i didn't
um being accosted accosted his boldly
and aggressively
i don't i don't remember councillor
morris moving out of his chair
i'd like i'd like to ask councillor
morris if he did go and accost
mr kelly when that council morris is
allowed to speak german
and i think i think that's that's all
i've got to say at this stage chairman
thank you
okay well now go if everyone's finished
counselor jarvis and then counselor none
chairman okay
councillor jarvis and councillor none
yeah thank you chairman um just a few
points really i think with regards to
the letter and the sort of
well actually the bullying nature within
that letter use of the word accosted
sort of
which we've doesn't seem to be much
evidence of what i would consider to be
accosting
uh in the light of day and i think um
you know i
it cuts nothing with me if somebody says
if you don't do something
i'm going to take it further but i
really don't like that and i think
uh uh town councillor stills to sum that
up quite well we shouldn't
uh we shouldn't in any way and that
shouldn't influence um
our decision today as far as the
substance uh look we've spoken earlier
about uh
the style of counselor maurice um yes he
wears a cap
puts his feet up maybe takes some calls
uses a megaphone look these are not
things i would do
these are not things i would encourage
him to do
but i think we heard earlier on that you
know he has a number of issues
but he is keen to uh draw to the
council's attention
and these are um these uh extravagant uh
extrovert ways of dressing or acting to
a degree
uh are to draw attention to himself and
he would say i'm sure to draw attention
to issues that he thinks the council
needs to be aware of now
i'm not saying i agree with them i i
it's not necessarily a style or
a way of operating that i would respect
but i do
understand uh to a degree why he has
behaved
in that manner i hope that going
forwards he won't feel
there are the same substance reasons
underneath that he will necessarily
uh need to act always in that manner but
look if he wants to wear a cap
into council meetings i don't really
have an issue with that it's not my
style but i think we've got to be very
careful
if we're adjudicating on everybody's
style thank you chairman
anybody else none
chairman ask the nun please thank you
chairman
um this is sort of it's a partly form of
a proposition i suppose but
um i agree with council jarvis that
you know it's not the way that i would
behave it's not the way that i would
dress
uh in the council chamber but having
said that
unless you tell me otherwise chair we do
not have
a counsellor code
uh there might be an individual party
dress code
but i don't know if it counts the dress
code and if that's the morris wants to
wear a cap
then i don't think that in itself is any
kind of breach however
um having reflected on this report and
listened
to councillor chandler the one thing
that troubles me
with this report is the reference to old
and i don't just say that because i'm
old uh i say it because
it is a protected
term and you know this morning we were
looking at
um uh homophobic comments and comments
about
age um i think are concerned
so i am worried about that aspect in
the context of the bridge although
interestingly i just heard that the
monitoring officer perhaps isn't
but i am concerned about that
anybody else i i think the council has
misunderstood me
i didn't say i wasn't concerned i said
uh chairman just for the sake of clarity
um that that mr jennings seems to be
not relating it to the part of the code
for uh
for equalities breach of equality's
legislation but more to the point of
disrespect
i didn't say i wasn't concerned um i
i am repeating what mr jennings has said
anybody else yes cancer stamp challenge
just a just a quick point um about the
uniform
um i don't think it's actually lawful to
actually say what people can wear when
they attend a council meeting or a
uh we're going into an office you can
have a dress code if your your
employees wish to sign up to it but i
don't think
uh counts um sorry counselor simon
quelch who's the expert on this could
actually support this i don't think
there is a law
that can be added to at this council can
it except for
advisory
do you want to comment on that simon
and the point that councillor stamp was
mating making i'm sorry
mating
i didn't understand the question that
councillor stan
is there a law simon quelch that states
that this co
this council or is there a law that
states that you can make people wear a
cert
dress a certain way i don't think there
is no there isn't
no thank you so so wearing a hat
or i don't know wearing knee length
boots or whatever you can do nothing
about
i think that's correct there is no dress
code
that forms a part of the council's
convention
the conventions um i think that's right
what members have said there may be
group rules but those are not council
rules
so um wearing of a cap in itself is not
a breach
of any convention that the council has
thank you is everyone finished now
anyone else
uh that's it for the moment chad members
you've jumped the gun councillor morris
should have been asked
questions for clarification of the
monitoring officer and he wasn't given
that opportunity
because you went straight into asking
questions
and then you can ask questions again
after that
councilor morris yeah great thank you
chair you finally noticed
that the council has jumped over me and
uh
it was gone before i had a chance to
bring it on okay i apologize for that
that's fine apology accepted i would
have stuck up for you but i'm a little
bit worried that if i stick up for
people
and stop and bullying you that maybe
i'll get brought before joint standards
but let's move on um the complaint
point one sorry 1.2
the complaint was made by a member of
the public
mr t kelly can i please ask the
monitoring officer
how long he has known mr kelly
and in what um in what professional
capacity
he has known former conservative
district councillor tom kelly
i don't know the exact year but i would
have said
i would have said i first met
tom kelly in 2002 he was a district
councillor
and district councillor sorry
was he a conservative district
councillor i believe he was in the
conservative group but
i'm also aware that he became an
independent as well
right so he's a former conservative
district councillor
yeah former district and independent
councillor yes
are you aware because we did have a
telephone conversation about this
is he not a serial complaint
i've never had a complaint
i've never had a complaint from him in
relation
to anybody um
i've had lots of complaints from a few
individuals
um i could give you the list if you like
but
um if you would like that list um
you had a conversation where you stated
that he was a serial complaint
you told me you told me that he was
renowned in the conservative party for
putting whinges in
now whether or not that was to monitor
the conservative group you told me that
he was always having rouse and putting
complaints in
now what i said was i never said he was
a
complainer because he's never made a
complaint to me i've never known
uh tom kelly
ask a simple question don't keep
badgering
um
i'm not having him say that i'm lying
i'm chairman i
i'm trying to answer the question
counselor morris interrupts me because i
don't give him the answer that he wants
and so i'm trying to get the honest
answer not the answer that he wants
so the the the answer is i have never
as a monitoring officer received a
complaint
i or as an employee of malden district
council received a complaint
from mr kelly what i said to you on the
phone was
that i knew mr kelly as a counselor
and he was very forthright in his views
and was quite ready i think my
recollection of the telephone
conversation i had with you
was that he was quite ready to go
against the party line
he was quite ready to stand up for what
he believed was right
those are the words i said to you i
never said he was a serial complainer
because i've never had a complaint from
him until today
that was my interpretation of what you
said that he was always having browsing
ways in it he was always bringing up
complaints well that's good
he is a former tory district councillor
that has been willed in for political
purposes
to put this complaint on to try and put
to try and put pressure on me
because i have exposed the bullying
culture
at mdc let's move on well can i just say
what you've said
is a distortion a complete distortion
counselor morris
conversation complete distortion a
misrepresentation
in its entirety you have your perception
of that conversation
i have mine let's end that one by
him after having put his questions as
we've just
heard accosted what a word accosted i
didn't go after him or anything like
that
i heard an absolutely rubbish answer
go to that gentleman and i knew the
answer to that gentleman and i politely
put the corrupt what i believe to be the
correct answer in
yet again i spoke my truth anyone can go
back
and hear what was said i was polite i
was respectful
and i thought it was disrespectful that
the chairman and the leader
would allow such a rubbish answer to be
given to him
i actually i actually agree with
councillor morrison
i was i was at that meeting and
i have to say i i was surprised
personally
by the use of the word accosted um
i don't recall um i don't recall
counselor morris doing something that i
would describe
as accosted but that was the complaint
that was put in
and um mr jennings has has looked into
that and given
his understanding of what mr kelly meant
by it
showing disrespect to the chairman was
the next one
and what i would say to that is i give
the respect i get so if
if if anyone thinks i was disrespectful
to the german
i gave the respect back that i was shown
by the chairman
and remember this is the chairman who
calls human rights legislation
rubbish that is disrespectful
um aggressive behaviour towards a
committee chairman
i don't think there's any questions for
me are they chairman shalom
i thought this was to go through the
report
councillor morris what else do you want
to say
yeah it's just to go through a little
box i'm going through the report
so and simon is welcome to come in
at the appropriate time to put his side
so now we've got
um aggressive behavior towards a
committee chairman
councillor council now i remember that
very very well
and what was said was that councillor
harker actually said
i'm too old for this and i agreed with
him
and then he aggressively shouted for me
to
shut up i didn't put no complaint about
that because i've got a thick skin
article 10 remember yeah i i didn't put
no whinge in about that
so how was i aggressive to a man that's
shouting across the train to shut up to
me
and that's all on the tape so he was the
one that stated
he was too old i agreed with him and he
chatted shut up to me so there was no
aggression from me whatsoever
then we've got um making
taking making mobile telephone calls i
have received text messages
from the former leader counsellor fluker
whilst we've been in the chamber that is
no
law break that that is no heinous crime
the next one disrespect of wearing a cat
i'm sorry but how is wearing attack
disrespectful
the the the background to that is that i
attended the council offices not for
any uh council meeting but
in you know in a private capacity
and i had um a small cut on my head
from shaving my head and i put a cap on
to cover the cut up
luca decided to try and bully me
and tell me that i wasn't allowed to
wear a cap indoors
i will not be told how to dress the last
person told me a dress
was my mum and that she don't do that no
more so he don't get the chance to
either wearing a cap indoors sound
pathetic found
rather than the clothes they are wearing
when i joined moulton district council
i spent money that i didn't have to buy
shirts and and
a suit jacket and stuff like that
because i was making an effort
that wasn't good enough i had the
the um officers requests
counsellor heard got me down a costa
coffee and said
you've got to wear a tire mate
i've made an effort i'm making an effort
now i'm in a shirt
i do want to try and get along but i
will not be told how to dress
um morris you're screaming from the
report again
please now i'm reading this
bringing the council away
what do you mean leeway you're telling
me that i'm straying from the report i'm
reading from the report
actions which would bring the council
into disrepute had the press being
present
the press are actually welcome to print
or do
anything i want sorry that i have done
i do not believe i've brought the
council into disrepute
anywhere near as much as what you
counsel a helm
thompson uh
so you are accusing me of something
councillor morris can we move on
can we move on accusing you of being
part of the bullying culture
at mountain district council councillor
morris you have strayed away from the
report there sorry to interject um but i
am the deputy chair or vice chair of
this committee
and i'm afraid
but you have strayed away from that can
you please carry on when you said about
the actions of the press please
counselor helm i'm sorry if i've
interrupted you but
thank you very much for helping me right
so
right so my next point would be everyone
is having a pop at me
for telling the truth or was he stood up
oh no he's
oh no he's got a phone call during a
meeting
come on councilor maurice please the
chairman i
go mike excuse me councillor helm does
that make
um my last uh one of one of these um
accusations about
using a mobile telephone does that not
sort of like put that into a little bit
of context because you've just done that
let's carry on
oh it doesn't matter counselor help you
just use your telephone
in a meeting which is one of the things
you guys have tried to hang me for
so let's just move on um
everyone's making a big thing about bob
about me saying that bob
was too old to do the job now let me
just take you back before
i uh when i tried to informally sort out
this bullying culture
i requested i sat down with bob we sat
in the members
office members room and bob was watching
the sweeney
so i sat with bob and we both watched
the sweeney and we had a nice old chat
and i said
informally to bob bob you know what's
going on
it ain't right fluke is bullying
councillor
things are not right here i'm straying
away again
no i'm not i'm explaining my point
let me explain my point i asked bob if
he could resolve it informally
to not bring the council into disrepute
to not put our dirty washing
in public i asked him if he was happy
and he turned to me and he said quite
simply
chrissy i'm too old he told me that
now there are other councillors and
there are other councillors in this
meeting right now that have confirmed
that and one of the councillors who i
won't mention
even though i feel like i should have
because i feel they're not being that
fair
actually told me that bob would not have
let this happen
10 years ago and he is being manipulated
by fluka
and he is diminished because of his
age i'm not having a go at him for being
old i like old people
i i'm an old person myself
what i am saying is that he is not the
man he was
10 years ago this would not have
happened and that has been confirmed
by senior conservatives so i'm not
having a go at him for being old i'm
simply pointing out
that he is past his best when you get
given an
mbe oba whatever it is that is a polite
way of saying
you are past it now i'm sorry if my
truth is
that's very offensive to a man
it's the truth he got booted out of the
county council because he
passed its best he's a nice old boy i
actually
quite liked him
chairman of this council again what can
you confine
yourself to the report
i'm not accused of the aegis thing yeah
i'm being honest
would not have got away with what he got
away with if bob was 10 years younger
that is something that sorry a tory
councillor
sorry the count the report here has
nothing to do with councillor fluke why
you bring him into it
well the situation is because of
councillor fluker
i would not have had to bring this up if
councillor polka
wasn't a homophobic woman threatening
bully
no we're not i don't know
michael you allowed you supported this
report
please
so tom kelly former conservative
councillor tom kelly
who've been put down as a um as a member
of the public
is a former conservative councillor um
uh yeah i may not do me that'll do me
this is politically motivated
this is done because um the dodgy
conservatives
um have got puey that i've exposed their
bullying
thank you
right members would you like to question
councillor
morris at all on any of this chairman
casachano has another question i think
for the monitoring officer yes
uh sorry chairman i forgot to ask this
um
hang on first time um yes i'm referring
obviously to the report that's before
the deputy monitoring officer and a
paragraph 1.5 specifically
and it's in relation to an officer of
the councillors at present to the
meeting where this all occurred
the strategy policy and communications
manager
it looks like that she was interviewed
or it says spoken so i don't know if
that was a statement
or just a mere conversation it just says
the word spoken
and they expressed their views and
disgusted horror at witnessing the
behavior
of um councillor morris from early in
the meeting i'm now quoting from
the report and about phone calls and
feats on tables and everything
um however she then goes on
um she then um she said with the
subsequent exchange of the chairman she
felt the effect of the behavior
displayed by councillor moyes was
embarrassingly
concerned and totally unprofessional she
then goes on to say
um because that's who that position is
strategy policy and communication
manager as a female at that time from
her experience in both the private and
public sector she considered that such
behavior was totally unacceptable in the
workplace and i'm just
homing in on that point sherman if the
monitoring officer can say this because
obviously the workplace is the council
but officers
are in the workplace whereas where this
activity was
that she's referring to was actually in
the chamber so
therefore was she um saying unacceptable
in the workplace where her normal
environment was
or was she meaning that actually what
she witnessed in the chamber which is
not essentially the workplace
is the chamber of council as elected
representatives
that she was meaning it was unacceptable
to that just for clarity chairman
because to me there's a difference
between the workplace and the council
meeting at full council
with elected political representatives
or otherwise
so i just like that distinction to me
made clear because her words were
such behavior was totally unacceptable
in the workplace
i understand that it was an interview
and i understand that what reading
trying to read everything in context
that she is saying that
from her experience in the workplace
this behavior
in the council chamber would be
quotes totally unacceptable in other
words
counsellors should be i think the point
she's making is counsellors
should behave in a respectful way and
you would expect
them to behave in the council chamber
not in a dissimilar way
to colleagues in the workplace in other
words
if this had taken place in the workplace
she is saying
this would have been dealt with this
would have been considered well i quote
the i quote the report totally
unacceptable
i think that's what i think that's
what's happening she's making a
comparison
let's ask your question counselor thank
you
anybody else yes um german councillor
jarvis and then cancer stamp
that's the jarvis please
how's the jarvis play yeah sorry thanks
chairman just finding the buttons
um yeah i think just uh three points the
first point is just with regards to the
uh two old statement which i think
other councillors have said is probably
one of the more serious
potential serious issues i think it
should just be put in
into context but i do recall the comment
it wasn't delivered i didn't feel in an
aggressive way i'm not saying it's good
thing to have said
but it wasn't delivered in an aggressive
way and i think perhaps
in some mitigation as well i have heard
counsellor bob boyce say
i'm too old for this job so look i'm not
saying it was a good
comment to make a clever comment to make
the council bob boyce has made that
remark
sort of himself and so uh um
i i don't think it was delivered in an
aggressive way
and i think those are sort of mitigating
circumstances from from making that
remark
i think we've we've talked a lot about
the dress code look
we've all said it's not the norm
necessarily it's not what most
counselors do
but with regards to how you dress uh in
the council you know look
there are there don't seem to be any
rules about it and i think
we've also heard that counselor morris
feels he has some points to deliver
he wants to draw attention to himself
for he would say
and there is some justification for that
and to draw attention
a number of issues to draw those to the
attention of the greater council
so look you know there is an argument
that that that was uh the greater good
that he was trying to deliver
and i think the only other point i'd
like to make uh chairman is i know that
uh
uh council morris has said on a number
of occasions here um that that's the
conservative party the conservatives
i just like to i'm a conservative
councillor i think there are some very
good conservative councillors
i don't think all of them have behaved
very well i think that's all coming to
light
i think some of them should be ashamed
of themselves but i think i would just
say
you know um would just caution him
please and
don't put everybody into that pot not
all conservative councils are like that
not all people who believe in
conservative values i like that
and i'd like him to think that going
forwards he will be able to work with
people and if they happen to be
conservative councillors
he would be willing to work with them if
they can demonstrate
good qualities which i know some of them
do have thank you
thank you very much anybody else
counselor stamp and then counselor keys
chairman
yeah well said again um councillor
jarvis that's excellent i
totally totally uh support you 100
voice of reason um can i actually ask
the monitoring officer
in regards to councillor chana's comment
uh 1.5
was everybody interviewed following this
meeting that was a member
an officer or was it just the policy
communications manager
um and i'm sorry if i've missed it but i
think there was more than the policy and
communications manager at this meeting
so it would does this go to i'm just
worried that this has gone to bias did
you did they inter
interview or speak to other people and
nobody else wanted to speak just the
clarity chairman please
um um i i i don't know chairman um
the extent of mr jennings
um investigation but if he'd have
interviewed others
then i'm sure he would have included
that in his report um
he he spoke to me in 1.5 that was in
relation to
in effect the instructions that i gave
him to to to carry out the report
to do the investigation so obviously i
have to i have to give him
the bare bones of what the case is about
as i do with with any person that i
asked to do an investigation
um i i don't think i don't think he
spoke to anyone
else other than
the council's strategy policy and
communications manager
thank you chairman i would ask that
question to follow up questions to that
then why not
if you're carrying out an investigation
and you want it to be full
open and transparent why do you not want
to speak to everybody
that was actually at that meeting at
officer level or
or whatever chairman it's just a point
that's sprung to my mind
uh we can't be selective we're all
asking questions it has to be fair
and i don't think by putting one person
i'm glad counselor channel knows who the
person they're speaking about because i
didn't
but it really does need to be open and
fair
uh well i'm sorry a councillor stamp
that you think the investigation was
unfair
and you must judge them please don't put
words in my mouth
please don't put words in my mouth sorry
to interrupt chairman
and so it's been took you mr quelch it
was that point
i was referring to yeah is that clear
well okay i thought you were saying
because of that the
investigation was unfair because other
people weren't investigated
that weren't weren't interviewed i
thought that's what you were saying no
sorry and i do apologize if you've
misconstrued but i think you went from a
to zed there in fred
instead of from a to b okay perhaps you
could clarify then because i'm sorry i i
i don't want to answer the wrong
question i'm sorry
okay all right hang on i'll put my
camera on my question was
did um what's his name mr jennings
asked everybody who was at present that
council meeting
and if not why not because to me
if you're going to speak to one officer
who was there you should speak
all of them that were there for a
balanced full
report i'm not saying what you said that
i've accused
anybody of anything so can we actually
just take this down a little bit
but that was my main point from my point
of view you would interview
everybody if you're carrying out an
investigation well i think that's a
matter for you to decide that if you
think that the investigation wasn't
complete enough mr jennings obviously
considered
that it was and that he didn't need to
he had
the thing is a point here is that he
listened to the audio
he wasn't present at the meeting but he
listened to the audio
so he actually had the whole of the
meeting
and listened very carefully to it and i
think he mentions that
he describes some of the things that he
heard
on the audio so when you've heard the
audio of something
um and you've you've interviewed
the complainant that was mr kelly
you've then interviewed an officer that
was at the meeting to obviously confirm
whether your understanding of the audio
is correct
then um personally i don't think
mr jennings investigation is incomplete
i think the really really important
thing was
listening to the audio and hearing
himself what was said
when it was said and how it was said
chairman uh chairman i think cats um a
lot of simon clutch and i are going to
slightly disagree with that disagree on
that point
i won't labor it too much further but
that's like saying i've got the first
answer i want to conduct the report
i'm not going to go any further thank
you um
i think that's the fear of counseling
to i think that's very important i i
don't
and i i did say you know i i i wasn't i
wasn't being difficult i
just don't think that's right we just
leave that and carry on please
if possible we've had a lot of arguments
and tools and frozen
we want to get to occlusion of this
meeting if we possibly can it's now
nearly four o'clock chairman we have
cancer keys next and then councillor
morris would like to come back on some
issues yes councilor keys first and
councillor morris can come back by all
means
has the keys hello can you hear me
yeah i can hear your counselor keys
carry on
can you see me yes i can see you now
i'm just um inquiring councillor morris
said that um
mr kelly was a conservative councillor
and also an independent
was he an independent council longer
than a conservative or vice versa i'm
just
inquisitive because i don't know mr
kelly
can someone answer the question please
simon and do you know the answer to that
question
oh just inquisitive i wonder if it was
one longer than the other
i don't know i'm just just questioning
this
simon you probably don't know then do
you i i'm sorry i i don't know the
answer to that i'm sorry
that's right i just wondered what it was
but okay thank you for letting me speak
thank you
that's all right just for information of
the committee
i was leader of the mould independent
democratic alliance for four years
and that was regarded as independent
i've been a conservative councillor
and now i'm a conservative not aligned
and shortly i'll be something else
so thank you for i just let you know
where i come from thank you
that's the morris
shortly you'll be something else that's
a bit cryptic michael
um i'd just like to come back to uh the
officer
uh georgina button um i
i do believe that the uh whole thing was
very narrow the investigation was very
narrow
you ask i'd like to just say that stuart
jennings isn't present to answer any of
the questions
when he should be after i requested that
all people
be available to answer questions because
uh
obviously we'd be able to get more
concise answers
um but um georgina button the
communications
officer uh that said what was it disgust
um horror and disgust well i i just i
would wonder
how she would view the homophobic
threats to women
um that has been in that chamber whether
or not you know
we're talking about you not anybody else
now we're talking about that she said
she felt
horror and uh disgust and i'm i'm simply
putting it into a context
what i've done is nowhere near as bad as
what fluke has done
which she's been she's been sitting in
and is fully aware of
so you know and i want to point out that
it was a
very narrow narrow investigation
um and no one else would want stuart
jennings got
the um got the uh in got the
the statement that he wanted and then
decided not to
bother getting any others and quite a
lot
of that meeting was put on my youtube
and if you guys want to see what other
people think about that
you've got some other people saying well
done chrissy
because believe it or not you guys are
in an echo chamber
and you've got very antiquated views
some of you um
and we need to appeal to the public we
need to be seen to be honest and appeal
to
the public and speak in layman's terms a
little bit more to
encourage people to get involved in the
political system
and forward their community thank you
thank you very much for that christy
morris thank you very much councillor
morris
be currently direct right members that's
right
that's all right michael i prefer to be
called chris evan councillor
okay thank you for that
um members i've got to move on now
in accordance with procedure for
complaints determination 0.8
i will now call the committee to
determine if there has been a breach of
code of conduct
please use the chat function to indicate
if you wish to speak
berna can you tell me if anyone wants to
speak
no not at the moment german
nobody at all no
so do members think councillor boris has
breached the code of conduct
did anyone want to speak
[Music]
sorry chairman um there's no prop caster
jarvis is asking if there's a proposal
on the table for this
second matter um and i
i haven't heard a proposal as yet no i
haven't that's what i'm like waiting for
is there a proposal please
uh counselor mays i think would like to
put forward a proposal
councillor myers please
thank you mr chairman um having listened
to everything
and from personal experience of some of
these types of
um uh situations
i honestly cannot see that there is
any evidence to support um
one the the the four comp there's five
complaints that are listed
and therefore i do not um i want to
propose that um
that there has been no breach of um
any of the code of conduct okay have we
got a second or for that
i might be a second man okay
uh anyone want to make a discussion on
that
no discussion right yes please chairman
can i ask ask for a proviso or something
and uh two more minutes i think
thank you chairman i appreciate that the
only concern i've got and i know
councillor morris
did explain uh when he used the word
that
um councillor boyce was old or too old
i'm the same as councillor nunn and i
can remember sitting in the chamber
when councillor morris because he sits
behind me said that and i did
gasp audibly and so
depending on how the vote goes because
we don't know how it's going to go
go chairman could we suggest
something for all councillors or council
morris that we have as a council
a massive diversity training for
everybody that can benefit this council
to go
forward i don't know if that can be put
on as an amendment if it's planning
chairman i'd say put it as a condition
simon quelch might have to help me to
put that one in but i really do
feel we need to have um
more diversity training uh which one i
think might help councillor morris as
well
he may not agree with me but that's my
point of view let us deal with the first
bit and then i'll have a vote on whether
everyone should have diverse
training sorry chairman sorry constant
jobs would like to just make a point
yeah thanks chairman um yeah i take the
point uh when your stamps um
cancer stamps mentioning there i think
that's a good idea but
um you know i think the proposal on the
table is uh you know how has been
discussed
we we none of us think it was
necessarily a sensible thing to say
uh to cancel the voice i don't think
anyone's thinking it was necessarily
sensible but as i have said
already i don't think it was delivered
in an aggressive manner and it's only a
comment that council boys have made
himself
so it's a fine judge thing i i think it
was an ill-judged comment
but i i don't think uh uh i i would you
know find that he brought the council
into don't disrepute because he'd
he'd said it which i think is you know
what's before us and we've some
we've discussed uh in detail uh
about dress codes and all of the other
points that are on there
and you know we might not agree with the
way that council morris dresses but i
don't think again
there's been any breach and i think um i
think that's really the issue here
um we none of us or most of us don't
necessarily have the same style
uh the council morris has and um and i
don't i doubt very much whether he will
immediately adopt
uh the style of others but the fact is
we're here to judge
in a way whether he's uh behaved in a
way
uh whether he's uh uh performed in a way
but has brought you know the council
into some form of distribute
and i i i just uh in terms of obviously
i seconded the proposal i i
don't believe that is i don't believe
that's the case of course i i hope he
takes all of the comments that have been
given
by many councils today to him i hope he
takes those on board
um so that he can be as i've said
already today he can be more effective
we could be a more effective council
but i think in terms of adjudicating in
any way on
uh on on his actions in terms of
bringing the council into disrepute
um although i don't agree with what he's
done in some cases i think we're asked
whether he's brought the council into
disrepute i don't believe that's the
case
thank you chairman okay so anyone else
who wants to comment
counselor channel chairman ask the
channel please
um thank you um chairman i heard what
council java said councillor
um stamping council and i'm regarding um
the comment regarding council boys and
that's the one i i have real issue with
um in the chamber saying you're too old
um you need to quit
um it is a protected characteristic um
as councillor nan said he's old uh
council morris has identified his old
i'm old and i have i have more than one
protected characteristic
and i do think we need to be mindful of
that and the fact that council and boys
might have had
said something in a private conversation
to councillor morris i do respect that
and hear that however
this happened in the chamber the comment
was wade council stamped quite right she
did audibly gasps she looked actually
quite shocked from where i'm sitting i
could see her and what i would say is
members of the public
um would not appreciate about that
private conversation council morris
referred to they would merely hear
councillor morris saying in the chamber
to the chairman
you are too old you need to quit and
therefore
i think actually the word and counselor
sorry simon quelch answered that
question
it doesn't go against 3a of the code of
conduct that's quite clear however
the issue of disrespect one
would perhaps have to say um that that
could be very much interpreted as a
matter of disrespect regarding the
chairman
highlighting um his age and well telling
him really he's too old and needed to
quit
and that's what i would have to say on
that chairman
okay we've got a proposition on the
table put forward by
can you remind me german
and what was that proposition that there
was no breach of the code
in all five areas and seconded by
councillor jarvis
okay can we do you want to record it
vote everybody
yes yes please
can we um yes please yes please
chairman chairman can i just ask can we
not do anything about the protected
characteristic though because councillor
chana
and myself and i you know i know cancer
jarvis said what he had to say
but i'm i'm totally supportive of most
of the motion
but i i'm really struggling chairman i
can't
i cannot vote on a motion that
um we're going to say uh protected
characteristic isn't taken into account
can that can we have simon quelch can
that motion be changed
you can make a counter proposal you you
have a motion on the table
that has been seconded and that includes
everything in other words everything
that stuart jennings has put in his
report including
uh council stamp what you just mentioned
about the
um you're too old comment that is all
included
in there being no disrespect so you you
can
in a way you can't amend it there either
was disrespect or there wasn't now
you can make it clear there was
disrespect in relation to
the two old but it's still disrespect
you can make it clear that all the other
aspects like the wearing of the cap
um like um the telephone calls
um the the alleged accosting
you you can you can make it clear that
that is not a part of your decision
but at the moment the motion stands that
um the the statement you're too old you
have to quit
is is not disrespect that that's the
effect
of the motion as it stands cancer stab
would you like to make a counter
proposal
well i i i don't know
not allowed to chairman okay i'm ready
we'll carry on
let's take the vote recorded vote please
can i just
check if council morris wants to come
back on something there i want to come
back
off the council maurice
thank you um just to reiterate
i wasn't having to go at the guy's age i
was having a go
that he's well i wasn't having a go i
was pointing out the truth
that he is not the man he was
10 years ago he would not have allowed
it to happen
there are councillors that have known
bob boyce
for years that agree with that i was not
having a go
at his age i was having a go he's
diminished
mental state because he wasn't he's not
the man he was
and he allowed as chairman he allowed
the bullying culture to flourish and
actually encouraged
i'm not having a report thank you
right chairman do
does the committee wish for councilman
to repeat her proposal just
one time before we go to vote or are we
okay
councillor maze will you repeat it just
for the benefit everybody please
counselor maze
um yes uh sorry mr chairman i had a
slight problem with
um unmuting myself um yeah um
the proposal is that um
councillor morris um has not uh breached
the code of conduct based on the
evidence that has been presented
um in this particular incident
thank you
members um i will call you
alphabetically as normal
can you please clearly for against
abstain counsel the passenger
if councillor boyce had made a complaint
it would be different but i'm voting for
yeah councillor chana
uh thank you i'm afraid i have to go
against
um i hear what's being said but i am
looking at the report
and the views regarding uh the old and
the
quit and the projected characteristic
regardless
and uh now councillor morris to me
mentioning mental health uh um or his
mental stuff
um that's why i'm having to vote against
i'm afraid now
thank you council helm
happen to agree with councillor channel
i'll vote against
mr jarvis
listen to the debate um for i'm
obviously seconding the proposal
that's the keys i've also listened to
the bay and i'm four
as well thank you councilman
four that's the nun
well i too am very concerned about this
uh
age issue but on balance or
that that was four councilman yes cancer
stamp
ditto with councillor none i am
still very concerned about it but
because we can't change the motion
it's it's too late thank you thank you
members that's
six
six four two against no abstentions
thank you thank you very much councillor
morris
you have not breached any code of
conduct
uh thank you chairman can i come back
after councillor yes yes
um i do think um it is very very
important
that the one thing that we do learn from
this is
uh that we need more diversity training
i i will reiterate both what councillor
stamp
and councillor jarvis and councillor
chana have actually put forward about
protected
um uh characteristics we had the same
issue this morning
and i think it is absolutely imperative
that we do take this forward
as a matter of priority thank you
simon councillor can we arrange training
if possible for every member
i know counselor fluker has already done
diversity training
well i think that's the matter that
needs to be taken up with the leader
um um i i think i don't think it's so
much for officers to do well i think
it's a matter for the leader to look at
the training issues of members
so so maybe members should be speaking
to the leader
um and and and dealing with that issue
obviously then officers can be given an
instruction if
if to go out and try and find a trainer
to give
training on that particular issue maybe
someone
make a motion to counsel yeah chairman
we can do that but even if the other
councillors it doesn't need to go to
full council you as the chairman
if we can we can't do it now because
it's not on our agenda but at the next
meeting
if we even if we have a meeting without
actually hearing any
complaints we could set the terms of
reference we could identify
training needs and then we could put
that to council so we can actually do it
professionally
to actually move this council forward in
a professional manner rather than
um i don't mean rather non-professional
but you know what i mean so it's
actually controlled and measured
chairman we could do that
thank you councillor stamp for that um
did you want to say something councillor
morris
yes please mike you know may i always
want to say something yeah but um
yeah um guys thank you ever so much
we've come to the right decisions things
have worked
you know as they should have done um the
one thing i'd say about the diversity
training is you cannot diversify the
truth
if it's the truth it can't be
diversified but i
every day is a school day you can learn
something from everyone
and i hope everyone has learned what i
would like to say is that moving forward
i hope that everyone can work together
for the benefit of the district
and if i if i'm given nothing to expose
i won't be troubling anyone i won't be
bringing anything up
it's just that what i saw i found had to
be tackled and i tackled it
and we will be a stronger council for it
so thank you very much
members um let's hopefully all move
forward
i hope to work well with everyone even
though i'm not on no committees or
working groups
um and uh thank you very much thank you
for that councillor morris
uh bernard did you want to say something
you're flashing
oh apologies no no thank you very much
chairman
is there any uh
there's no further items to discuss i
closed the meeting at 1601 thank you